では皆様 よろしくお願いします
私ならね 今日は今日みたいなね
寒くてあまり天気も良くないしね
まあ来ないだろうと思いますけど
まあ家で冬眠の準備した方がいいんじゃないかなというような気分になりましたけど
本当に今日おいでいただきまして
どうもありがとうございます
えーと  話を始めましょうね
それから僕は一線回っていうかね
瞑想をちょっと紹介いたしますので
その時まあ全部式であり
儀式とかね お祭りとか行いますので
今ただ話だけにいたします
今日が本当に業が悪くて
業の話になってます で
あの このテーマを決めた時は
いくつかの小さな小さな大事なポイントが思い浮かんでね
普段聞こえられない 聞くことできないものがありまして
これを紹介した方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったんですが
まあ講演は間近になってくると
あれ 何でしたっけ？忘れちゃったんです
何を言いたかったんですかと
で かえってなんでこのテーマにしたのかいと
もう変えたくなったんですけど
もう遅いんだからね もう変えられないんですから
まあ一応このテーマで頑張ってみます
で 我々 この業っていう言葉を使う時は
まあ本当にこの実際は
この人生の流れありますね
生まれてというからずっと流れて変化していくんですね
まあそれについてなんでこうなったんだろうかというふうにちょっと疑問に思う時があるんですね
なんでこうなのかと  その時ですね
この業っていう概念が入ってくるのはね
そこで仏教は行というし
日本のキリスト教系の学校ではね
まだ心が清らかな子供たちにマインドコントロールするんですね
小さい時からいろいろわけのわからない
根拠のない いろいろ映画を見せたり
いろんなことをしたりして
そこをね この運命とか定めとかという概念を入れたがるんですね
なぜかというと 日本人の心にこの神という妄想概念を生み作るためには
いきなりちょっと難しいんですね
だから畑できてないんだから
まず運命とか定めとかね
決まりとかね そういうふうに決まってるんだっていうふうに
いろいろもうちょっと 완急付けた概念を植え付けて
その上に神というものを設定したいという
マインドコントロールの順番が日本ではそうやって決まってるんです
それから我々の人生っていうのは
もう神の計らいによるだとという答えもあり
まあとにかく今日考えてみましょう
どうって何でしたか？と
で タイトルは下に来て
一応文章は上に来るんです
あの 考えても終わらない
4つあります いわゆる考えてはいけないということなんですね
1 ブッダナン ビッカヴェー ブッダディスセワ アチンテイヨ ナ チンテイ タッボ チンテント ウッマ ダス ヴィガハ タス バギ アッス
ブッダナンというのはブッダたちの
ブッダディスセワというのは
ブッダたるこの...ブッダて何ですか？その領域
教義というかね まあブッダとはこういうこういうものだというね
このブッダに対するすべての情報ですね
これはアチンテイヨ 考えられませんよ
アチンテイっていうのは
もう何て言いますかね
考えても考えても終わらないんですからね
ビヨンド スコープ オフ ヒューマン thinking ということで
人間の範囲は飛ばす飛んでいるんですね
思考できる範囲はやんチンテント
それでも考えるならば
ウンマ ダス 頭がイカれてしまうと
ヴィガハ タスというのは
もうもうどうにもならなくなって
もう頭がもうパンク状態になってしまうというになりますよと
いわゆる狂ってしまいますよということですね
ブッダの教義は考えきれない
考えてはならない 考える人の心は狂気になりますと
ですから まあそこはやめましょうね
はい  2番目 ジャハイッサビッケジャハナヴィセヨアチンテイヨナチンテイタッボ
あのジャハイッサっていうのは瞑想する人のことなんですけど
まあそこそこ瞑想する人ではなくて
瞑想がすごく進んで ちょっと超越した精神状態になっていて
あのジャーナっていうのは禅定ですからね
この禅定の経験に入っている人々
その人々の禅定とは何かっていうことは
もう人間には考えることは不可能ですと
まあ禅定の第1にしても
この肉体から体心が離れるんです
で 肉体から離れる心はどう機能するのかっていうことは
これは全然わからないでしょう
最低その人にさえも理解できないんです
どうなってるのかと この心はと
我々の場合はちゃんと鎖 5つで心が縛ってるんだか縛られてるんだから
肉体から離れられないんですね
だからその範囲で これはもう肉体から解放されると
もう時空間系超えてしまうんですね
あの空間は消えてしまうんです
認識に だからこれってちょっと考えない方がいいんです
あの空間ない世界っていうのはね
禅定修行者の禅定の教育は考えきれない
考えとはならない 考える人の心は狂気になります
じゃあその 2つをやめましょう
で  4番目 カンムイパコビッケアチンテイヨナチンテイタッボヤンチンテントウマーダスイガハタスバハギアット
意味はゴート果報は考えても終わりがない
考える人の心は狂気に陥ってしまいます
で  4番目 ローカチンタン
世間の考察も考え 思考し尽くせるものではありません
思考する人の心は狂気に陥ってしまいます
まず  4番目 説明しましょう
ローカチンタンっていうのは
世間について考える これはまあ大体宇宙なんですね
空間的な世界 仏教では世界といえば
この生命にも世界というし
空間的なスペーシャル世界
宇宙 世間というんですね
宇宙にも これ どちらでも考えきれられないんですけど
よく仏教は宇宙論はもうやめた方がいいという立場を取っているんですね
これはもう人間には思考しても思考しても
これは終わりがないんだよと
で この現代はね いろいろ数学発展しているんだから
それからね そういう計算するバカでかい機械もできちゃって
あの またね まあスペースからね
いろいろデータも取れるように
機械もね 開発しているんだから
いろいろ推測するんですね
宇宙はこうなった ああなったとかね
で ほとんど直接の経験というよりも
あれ 推測的な結論に立ってますね
最近のものを取った学説についても
この宇宙は拡大膨張しているんだというね
それで膨張してるんだってこと知ってましたけど
膨張は拡大スピード 拡大してるんだっていうことはわかって
で びっくりしてね どうやってわかった？これ計算したんですよ
それだけのこと まあいくつかのデータを取って
パルサーでしたっけ？そのカラフル光のね
スピードを計算して それでパルサーの進出
何でしたっけ？超新星でしたっけ
で まあ拡大膨張してるんだというね
じゃあ実際拡大膨張してるんだっていうことは直接経験はありえないんです
ただ コンピューターが計算して答えを出してくれるというね
計算の結果なんですね
そこで現代的に考えたっても
宇宙っていうのは何者かどう何者ではなくて
どんなものか どうなっているのか
どうなるのかとかね それも考えきれないんですね
あんまりにも膨大ですよ
で よく言っていることをね
宇宙の物質もほんのわずかしか知らないんだと
我々知っている物質 空を見ると星が見えますね
で その見える物質 経験できる物質っていうのは
まあなんか日本訳もありますね
あの本ではね ありましたっけ
日本訳は えっ  4%しか知らないんだと
残り 96%の物質は知る方法がないんです
だから現代科学知識で宇宙を知ったっても
たった 4%で それもろくに知ってるわけじゃないんです
残りの 94%の物質って何なのかと
だからそれはダークダークマターというね
暗黒物質って名前だけつけてるんですね
だからもう大量に物質がなければ
本当に質量のあるね 宇宙はこんな形にならないんですね
いわゆる固めていること不可能なんですね
膨張のエネルギーも不可能になっちゃうんですね
これ なんで拡大膨張するのかというと
このダークマターのパワーがもう押してるんですね
いわゆる反重力的なエネルギーがいっぱいありまして
反重力的な物質があって
だから地球では見ることはできない
地球の重力に従う物質しか我々に見ることできない
そういうことでも ただ単に聞いてみると面白いだけで
えっ？ということになるだけで
だから何と聞けば何ともないんですね
だからそれ すごく時間無駄になるし
考えきれなくなりますから
お釈迦様が考えたのは
この人間の脳のあのデータ処理できる範囲を考えて
このデータ処理できる範囲を超えたものにアクセスすると
もう頭がパンクしちゃいますよと
これってもったいないでしょ
だからやめてくださいと
では  3番目に入ります
で  3番目はカンマ・ヴィパーカなんですね
業と言ったっても過去
で 過去っていうことは
もう人間には考えきれない項目なんですね
また 人間の脳の処理能力
範囲はもうドカンと超えているんですね
だから全く理解不可能なんです
それでの調子に乗って考えるならば
頭がイカれますよと だから考えていけないということなんです
そういうことで 今日の話はここで
終了します だって お釈迦様は考えるといけないと言ってるんだから
じゃあ皆様はどうぞ考えてください
私はやっぱり遠慮したいと思っています
はい 次 あの命と業っていうのことをね
今日は特別に仏教のポイントだけ申し上げることにいたしました
なぜかというと あの皆様に出しているパンフレットを昨日読んでみたら
私が普通に分析する話す項目
全部そちらで書いてあるんですね
世間ではどうなっているのかとか
あれやこれやとかね そうっていうことは
お前仏教の話だけ喋って帰ってくれっていう意味ではないかなと
ですから この世間の状況に合わせることは今日はやめて
経典にあるものだけ それもほんのわずかな一部だけ紹介することに決めた
命とは業のこと このまま理解してください
命は知ってます？命って何ですか？と
皆様も一人一人は一個一個の命ですからね
ですから どんな単語を入れ替えても構わない
私は業ですと言っても構わない
生きているとは業のことですと
だから業を理解するためには
もう命そのものは何なのかと理解しなきゃいけないんですよ
で パーリ語の出てくる用語はカンマッスカタです
業を自己とすること 業自性という風に一応訳してされてます
普通仏教の世界では これは日本の先生方はカンマッスカタは日本語に訳するプロの方々はね
この単語を当てはめています
ですから 私にはわからないんですけど
皆様にはわかるでしょう
で 私の説明に入ります
生命とは業で 業で作られているのです
点は余計ですけど で 業で作られてるんですね
命の材料は業ということです
その意味は まあ考えれば簡単ですね
私の体は何でできているのかといえば
答えは業でできているんだよと
ですから 体そのものは業なんです
ということは 物質的な体も精神
心も業という材料でできているということです
肉体だけではなくて 我々の心も感情も気持ちも精神もすべて業で出来上がって作られているんです
ですから 業はわからないと思ったら
自分の爪でも見たら これも業でできているんだからね
髪の毛いっぺん取ってみたら
あ これも業でできているんですからね
調べてりゃわかるでしょ
業って何なのかと 自分というそのものが業なので理解しきれないだけです
神秘 まあ秘密 神秘はありません
あの ですから業が隠れているわけじゃないんですよ
このまま業だから 業という材料でできているんだから
これってよくわからないんだよという必要はないんです
業は摩訶不思議で神秘だよと
はっきりあるんだけど
理解しにくい 宇宙と同じなんです
宇宙ははっきりあるんだけど
4%しか知り得ない それもガタガタいい加減で
もうほんのわずか知ってるだけで
しかし宇宙は隠れているかというと
全然隠れていないんです
そういうことで 業も別に隠れているわけじゃないんだけど
まあ我々たちにはなかなかまあわからないだけですね
そのポイント大事ですよ
このみんな この神秘が好きなんですよ
だから本当にお釈迦様の教えよりは
いい加減アホなこのティベットの人々の話をすごく大事にするんですね
ティベット仏教はすごいやと
まあすごいですよ だって全部嘘言ってるんだから
あの悟りたければ チベットの坊さんはだいたい 40 万ぐらい取りますけど
マントラ一つ伝授してくれるんです
あなたどんな程度で悟りたい？と聞いて
それに合わせて はい このマントラですよと
じゃあマントラくれる
あのラーマがリンポチェがね
もう悟ってるかというと違います
私はまだ次 こういうところで生まれる予定やと
まだ予定があるんですね
自分たちはよく捨てません
チベットで生まれ変わったっても
何か面白いかよくわかりませんだけどね
まあ単純に生まれ変わりたい
生まれ変わりたいと思ってるばっかりの人々なんですね
ですから この仏教は神秘ないんですよ
はい 次に行きます 業は相続するもの
パーリの言葉はカンマラーヤーだ
で 命生き物が業を相続するんですね
生まれる瞬間に業という生かされるエネルギーを相続して
この世で生命が現れるんです
この世といっても 人間だけではなくて
どんな世界でも生命が生まれる瞬間で
結構あの財産を相続しているんです
で この財産を相続して
どんな生命も生まれるんですね
この財産は業と呼ぶんです
財産という言葉がちょっと違いますから
生かされているエネルギーにしてください
なんかすごいパワーがあって
我々はもうとにかく生きているんですね
もうもう諦めません とにかく生きている
これでいっぱい失敗すると
もうもう嫌になっちゃいますね
生きることが そうなってくる人々は
生かされているエネルギーを全部取って自殺しちゃうんです
自殺するためにも相当エネルギーが必要なんです
だからもうおかしいんですよ
それぐらいエネルギーを絞ることできれば
生きてみればいいでしょうに
まあまあ ちょこちょこっとエネルギー使って生きてみる
生きていられるしね これでちょっと失敗したところで
とんでもない気持ちになっちゃって
もう俺は自殺してやるぞということで自殺を図るんですけど
これまたものすごいエネルギーが必要なんです
とにかく死ぬまで我々は生かされているエネルギーがありまして
それはだいたい誰でも実感できると思いますよ
なんかじっとしていられない
何かしなくちゃいけないというエネルギーはいつでもありますよ
これが我々は相続する業なんです
したがって 他の生命に自分の命
生き方 性格 能力 幸福などをそう簡単に管理すること
変えることなどはできません
これが理解してほしいポイントなんですね
各生命が自分が相続しているエネルギー
財産を持っているんです
それを使って生きているんです
だから他人様にこれ自己管理などほとんど不可能なんですよ
私が言ったんだからって人は自分の性格を変えるのかというと
そう変えません お母さんが勉強しろよと言ったんだからといって
子供は勉強するというふうには決まりないんです
で 皆様方は認めてこないでしょ
人間は管理できないでしょ
管理できると思っているんですからね
人間っていうのは管理できないんです
言う通りにやらないんです
これ 人が自分を管理しようとすると
もう常識な人間なら腹が立つんです
どうしても管理してほしいと思っている人々は
まあ一応病院に行って調べてもらった方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい 旦那様 言う通りにいたしますという性格だったらね
で これはもう犬猫にもありえないことで
動物さえも管理してほしくないんですね
管理不可能ですよ だから我々は人間関係やらいろんなことでかなり苦労して
いろんな研究して 調べて
どうやって管理するのかとかね
マネジメントというのはもうもうものすごい膨大な学問にもなっているでしょうに
マネジメントの中でも各分野がね
ビジネスマネジメント
商売の管理 それからインダストリアルマネジメント
工場とかね そういう管理どうするのかとかね
それからパーソナルマネジメント
人間の管理どうするのかとか
大学に行ったらそれぞれの分野 1個決めて
マネジメント全体的じゃないんです
また小さな分野一つ決めて研究してしなくちゃいけないんです
はい それでアメリカの優秀な大学でマネジメントを卒業したんだからといって
いい管理者になるのかといえば
そうにもならないんですね
たまたま人にはその能力がある場合もありますよ
あのゴンザンみたいにね
もう倒産しつつある会社をね
ちゃんと管理して もうしっかり蘇って
堂々と商売できるようにしてあげたんですし
しかし みんなにはそれはできないんですね
私はこれを皆様覚えた方がいいんですよ
簡単に人の管理できないんだと
だから子供を産んだんだからといって
お母さんたちが調子に乗ったらダメなんですね
一番最初に子育てる親が悩む問題もそれなんですね
私はどうすればいいんですかと
この赤ちゃん育てる場合は
赤ちゃんを見ると いかに管理不可能な存在なのかということがものすごくわかるはずなんです
だからみんな間違ったやり方でね
赤ちゃんにすべて合わせてやるという
親が子供の奴隷になっちゃうんですね
子供の言うことは何でもやってあげたりとかね
これで世界迷惑な人間になってくるんですよ
若者になって十八になってくると
自分でも何すればいいかわからない
どんな勉強をすればいいか
どんな仕事をすればいいかとかね
全く見つかりっこはなくて
途方に暮れちゃって もう嫌な存在になっちゃうんですよ
元気が一番必要な時は全く元気がなくなっちゃうんです
学校を辞めたり 色々とんでもないことをするんですね
だからこの難しいんですよ
赤ちゃんとかね 一切とかね
言うことをやってあげないと
向こうはえらく激怒して
ものすごい攻撃する それで泣かせてはあかんから
もうなんとか何とかすると
これでどんどんその調子で親を管理しようと子供は思うんですね
これ逆でしょうね 親を管理したら何にもならんでしょうに
だから日本でやっぱり親子関係っていうのは
子が親を管理する世界ですね
だからうまくいってないとは思いますよ
だから この業のこのポイントで
あの あの話が難しいんだったら
私に文句言わないでください
最初から言いましたからね
これは考える項目じゃないんだと
ですから 今日話を聞いて終わった途端に電話してください
あの百登板とかね で とにかくお医者さんに見せてもらってください
もうそこはできません
相当難しいんです まあ最低ね
人を管理するということはそう簡単ではありません
と これは本来は不可能であるということだけ覚えておきましょう
性格が悪いが不幸にならない人も
その反対もいるんです
それでよくよく世の中で歩くと
性格はどう見ても悪いんだけど
結構うまくいっている
不幸にならない そういう人々はいるんですよ
やることはとんでもないことばっかりやっていけるのに
全然大丈夫ですね またいるんですよ
本当に真面目で素直で正直で
悪いこと何もしないで生きてるんだけど
何一つもうまくいかないんですね
これなんだこりゃと これは自分の相続の問題なんですよ
いいものを相続していると
もう今の生き方はそれほど関係なく
一応幸せで生きていられる
大したものは相続していないと
もう頑張っても大したことじゃないという結果にはなります
だから世の中でこの必ずしも悪人が負けくじを引いて
善人がもう勝ちくじを引くってことはないんですよ
で 真面目で頑張ってるんですけど
もう真剣に仕事をしているんですけど
あんまりうまくいかない人もいる
仕事はサボりたい放題サボって
もう悪いことやりたい放題やってるのに
もう仕事はどんどんどんどん上に行っちゃって
課長に社長にまでなって終わる人もいるんですね
そういうことを見るとすごく悔しくて腹が立ちますね
なんで良い人間がうまくいかないのかとかね
なんで悪人ばっかしうまくいっているのかとかね
考えちゃうと腹が立ちますよ
まあ腹が立ったっても
これは生まれる時もすごいパワーを相続しているんだから
業というものすごいエネルギーをね
これかなわないんですよ
一般の人は運命 定め カルマなどの概念で微妙に業のこの特色に気づいていますよ
一般の方々はなんて言ったっけ？ああ
あれはあいつの運命ですねとかね
そんな定めですねとかね
それはカルマだよとか何とかいう場合は
この子の相続する業に微妙に
感じているんですね それから業は起源なんです
これは難しいポイントですよ
オリジンですよ まあダーウィンさんが書いたオリジンのスペーシスではなくて
宗教の世界でもこのオリジンというというについて語ってますからね
地球はこうやって現れた
空が それからそれから空がこうやって現れたとかね
順番よくおかしいんですけど
それから人間を作って
それから動物を作るとかね
そういうふうにオリジンのストーリーを物語を語っていて
それはいろいろ世界でいろいろ文化でストーリーは同じじゃないんですけど
で 仏教から言えば 業は起源なんですね
それはカルマ用にという言葉なんです
ようにとは このあれ どう読むんですかね
体ですかね たい まあ地球生生まれること
起源 原因などの意味です
業が生命を生み出すのだということですね
だから生命を作ったのはもうおなじみ
繰り返すようになるかもしれませんだけど
業が初めて生命を誕生させるんです
神という超越した存在が創造するのではないんです
仏教ではこの神という概念は全くもないんですね
最初から馬鹿にしているんです
それはもう頭は相当イカれてる人しかそんなアホなことを考えませんよということに捨てているんです
しかし この理解しにくい業というエネルギーがどんどん生命を生み出すんです
ですから 少々差というのは業のことです
業とは自分そのものでもあるので
創造主にお願いして特別に VIP 扱いしてもらいたいと思っても
これは無理です なんか人間それやってるんですね
神に祈るんですね 自分のことを特別になんとかしてちょうだいと
しかし 実際存在する少少さは業なんです
逆に言えば 業というのは自分そのものなんです
だからどうやって祈りますかね
自分に もう繰り返しませんだからね
もう鏡見て祈るしかないんですね
鏡見てもうなんとかもう私をこれこれやってくださいと
まあ祈りなんかね 考えただけでもすごい詐欺的な考えですからね
神が作ったならば祈ってはあかんでしょう
に これは冒涜することになりますね
神を だって何か私が忘れたことでもあるのかい？と神が思うでしょう
で 神もアホで祈る 祈りなさいと言うんですね
祈ったらやってあげるぞと
それも相当なアホで 祈るまでわからないのかと
全知全能でしょうにと
全知全能ですけど 我々は祈って願をかけないか
何もやってくれないんですね
ではやってくれるかというと
それもないんです 我々は頑張らなきゃどうにもならないんです
祈るによって得るものはゼロ
何もないんですけど とにかく仏教はそれはもうないんですね
神学で世界の不公平の説明できないのは
業ではなく神を妄信しているからです
そこで神学者たちがものすごく苦労していますよ
神は全知全能で無限の憐れみを持っていて
もうとても優しい方で
あれやこれやと言うんですね
完璧で完全で しかし世の中は不公平だらけで
苦しいことだらけで もうどうにもならんですね
だからそれは何なのかと説明することは
神学者は今も苦労しているんです
膨大にテキストありますよ
ある神学者はこう言うんですね
神は全知全能で慈しみな溢れてます
世界 森羅万象を創造した
それから自動回転に任せて
神は無関心でいると だからこんなものになっているんだと
だから祈ろうか 祈るな
祈るまいか もうあんま世界はまあ自動回転やと
言うと神は創造する者に対して無関心だろうということ出てくるでしょ
これでもう一人はこれはまずいんだと
神は無関心でいるわけじゃないんだと
無関心ということは慈しみ
憐れみはないということになるんだよと
だから完璧に憐れみがあるんだから関心があるんだと
関心があるんだったら
なんでなかなかやってくれないのかと
それは神がやがて解決するまで待ってるんだと
もういろいろ言うんですね
だから 何も証拠なく いくつかの妄信があって
固定概念があって それからもう考えちゃうんですね
だから生命の起源は業なんです
それから親族っていうのは業のことなんです
パーリ語でカンマバンドウというんです
生まれてきた人は親族によって守られ
育てられるのです 死ぬまでこの絆は切れないんですね
我々はもう空から突然現れた人っていうのはいません
日本では何人かいるみたいですけどね
もう竹なんとか物語とかね
まあ桃から生まれたとかね
それでも桃から生まれるんだからね
まあそういうのは神話で
別に現実的な話ではないんですから
実際は世の中で誰でも親がいて生まれるんですよ
ですから親族がいるんです
そこで我々には その親族関係はもう切ることはできないんです
私はどんな人間になっているのかというと
この親族がどのように育てたかってことでしょう
だから現在 私たちの態度
生き方 性格 あれやこれやとかね
すべて親族の管理の結果になっているんですね
そのように私 しかし 家出することもできるし
親族と全くも関係なく逃げてしまうこともできるし
しかし 本当の親族っていうのは業なんです
業からは逃げられません
業はスーッと自分を守って管理しているんです
自分が何者になるかはほとんど親族の手によるものです
生命は業によって守られて育てるのです
どのようになるかはほとんど業の働きによるものです
私たちはどんな人間になるのか
どんな言葉を喋るのか
どんな性格なのか どんな仕事をするのか
仕事で苦労するのか 楽をするのかとかね
結婚してもハチャメチャ地獄作るのか
あるいはもう幸せな家族を築くのかとかね
あれはもうほとんど業によってやらされているんです
あの人が死ぬまで業が責任取るんです
生まれて生きていて死ぬ
そのメインプログラム 3つ
業がやっているんです
生まれること 業の仕事
生きること それも業の仕事
それから死ぬこと それも同じ業の仕事です
その 3つの仕事はしっかりやっています
恵まれた ラッキーでした
ついてない 戦後 戦争の因縁などの言葉を語るとき
業のこの側面を誤解しているんです
我々 日常でよく使うんです
あーだきれたとかね あ
ついてたとかね あ ついてないとかね
時々ね まあ戦争の因縁とかね
あれというのは業の一つの特色を誤解しているんですね
日本ではこれはすごい商売ですよ
あの線祖供養して戦争を成仏させるという宗教もありまして
結構金取ります で なんか物事うまくいかないと
もうそういう時はこれはもうご先祖様の因縁やとかね
まあそう思って言ったりするんですけど
それはもうまるっきりインチキで
ちょっと待って 何か あ
それだけですね それから業は頼り
助けてくれというならば
業に頼むしかないんです
これはカンマパティサラナという言葉なんです
舞い上がっている時 足を引っ張るのも
困った時 助けになるのも
自分自身の業の力です
いつでも業が糸を引いているんです
生命は業に依存しているんです
業はもう本当に業に頼っているんですよ
業から解放されて自由自在に生きることは不可能です
これはできません 陸上の生命は力に頼る
水中の生命は水をよりどころにする
一切の生命は は業をよりどころによりどころにしています
このたとえで理解してください
水の中にいる魚は水から自由にならないでしょう
だから何に何をしようと魚は思っても
やっぱり水が頼りになるんです
敵から逃げましょうというと
水は助けてくれる それで自分を敵の口の中に放り込むのは水なんです
どうしようもないんです
陸上にいる我々は地球から離れませんね
飛行機に乗っても 陸上なんです
地球の引力があって飛行機が飛んでいるんです
そこがなくなったら飛行機の操縦できなくなっちゃうんです
飛行機は丁寧に操縦して目的地に行く場合は
地球に引っ張られていることがとても大事なことになるんです
しかし それがちょっと間違ったらみんな終わり
だから助けるのも殺すのも業でありますよ
そういうことで 飛行機の例えもよくいい例えなんですよ
地球に引っ張られているんだから
飛行機は離陸して飛びます
そこでちゃんと飛んで
この道を選んで飛ぶときも地球の引力が必要なんです
それから着陸するときでも同じことで
地球の引力は飛行機に効かないんだったら
着陸どうするんですかね
かえって着陸はすごい危険なことになっているのは
また同じ地球の引力なんです
ちょっと間違ったら全部終わり
ちょっと角度変わったら
ほんのちょっとでももう全部終わりという
そのように我々は頼りにしているのは業です
生命の それから業が差をつけるんです
生命の差を業がつけるんです
カッマンサッブヴィバゲティ
ヤリダンヒーナッパニータタエ
優れた生命になる 卑しい生命になるなどの生命の差異がそれぞれ業の働きです
この世の中で全く同じアイデンティティの生命はいないんです
一人一人が違うんです
神が作ったならば なんで工場で作ったような感じで均等に作ってないんですかね
だから神じゃないんです
どうというエネルギーが作ってるんだから
一人一人が違うんです
一個人が自分を他人と比較してみるのです
自分の幸不幸を他人の幸不幸と比較するんです
それで差を感じるんです
比較しなきゃ差を感じません
私たちは  子供たちは家で兄弟と比較してみるんです
比較しても喧嘩するんです
結局はもうお母さんがお兄ちゃんのことばっかり可愛がってるんだとか
文句まで言うんです そうするとそんなことないんだよと言って認めませんね
これはもうお母さんのせいじゃなくて
それぞれ業が業が差をつけてるんです
学校に行ってももう差が見えてくるんですね
同じ学校なのに 同じクラスなのに
同じ年なのに 同じことを勉強しているのに
もう一人一人が違います
個人が納得いくかいくまいか
それに関係ないんです
時々みんな何か怒ってるんですね
この世の中の差には みんな均等にしなくちゃあかんやとかね
えらいことをやってますよ
こう成り立たないんです
昔ね 共産党の政権では
もう労働者の世界を作りましょうと
みんな平等にしてやるぞと
できたんですかね たったたった半年ぐらいでも平等な世界あったわけじゃないんです
今はもう共産主義といえばもう北朝鮮だけですけどね
あの国だけはすごい みんな平等ですね
金正日さんとみんな同じご飯食べて
一般国民も生活しているんですかね
とんでもない結果ですよ
国民は奴隷で 金家族だけは神様で君は終わりと
それでじゃあ民主主義世界はね
自由経済世界は平等を作るかというと作りません
これは決してありえない
このユートピアという言葉がありますね
これはありえないんです
で 個人的には気に入っているか
気に入らないか そんな知ったことはないんです
現実的には不可能です
授けるのは業です 生命は本来平等ですが
決して同一にはならないんです
すべての生命は業に業が生んで作るんだから
生命は平等ですよ しかし
同一イコールにはならないんです
この今の業の説明は このチューラカンマ・ヴィパッサナースッタンという経典にある一行の説明です
はい それから少々ごく普通の説明に入ります
業と差別 カルマカンマという言葉をよく知られているのですが
誰もこの意味をわかっているとは言えないんですね
このカルマという言葉っていうのは
今 世界中誰でも知っているんです
で そのまま世界のどんな言語にも入り込んでいるんです
英語の辞書を引いてみてもあるんです
その場合はカルマなんですね
カンマっていうのはパーリ語です
しかし 誰もわかってない
これ何なのかと 人を差別するために
社会の不公平を認めるために
権力を誇示するために
業という概念に逃げる人もいます
そこで不幸な人を見てね
これはあなたのカルマでしょということで
もう人を差別するんですね
権力者が もう我々はそういう業で生まれたんだから
もうしょうがないだろうっていう
やはり自分の権力を誇示するんですね
とにかく人を差別するために
業という概念を使うんですよ
わかっているのかい 人は自分の過去の業を知らないので
その無知弱みを商売のネタにして
過去の業を占う詐欺師たちもあ
溢れています そこでよくあることっていうのは
このヨーロッパにもありますよ
まあチベットで学んだとかなんとかとか言って
もうあなたの過去の業はこんなものやあんなものやとかね
言っていて 私は日本はそれは世界一優秀な国やと思いますけど
業を占ってもらう国としてはね
もう誰にでもお釈迦様も考えたらあかんやと言ってる概念ですけど
これプロができてるんですよ
どれほど詐欺師かと で
私にも一部説明できますよ
どれほど難しいかと 業っていうのは
今日はそこら辺は全部カットしています
まあいくらか頭いかれない程度に話をかなりもうカットして今日出してますからね
あんまり心配しないでください
頭いかれない程度で終わってます
終わりにします で 本当に業の働き
説明しちゃうと相当大変なんです
だから仏典はむちゃくちゃ調べている私たちも
最終結論はこれはわかりません
お手上げだということなんです
これで占ってくるんだから
何時はこの もう何て言いますか
戦争の五回前とかね 五代前
最近ある人が言ったんです
自分の家内にはこう言われたんだと
宗教からはね 仏教からはね
五代前か十 四十代前かのなんとか戦争が
このちょっと精神的にすごく不安で納得いかないで死にましたと
だからあなたの娘さんには子供は差し借りませんと
見事な占いでしょう このお母さんの娘さんに子供がないんだから
お母さん困ってるんですね
で 占ったら この四十代前の戦争が
誰かがね ちょっと落ち着きがなく死にましたと
このこれは信じるバカっていうの
だからなんでこの子に子供が生まれない理由になるんですか
それが その今の娘さんが今の娘さんの業で生まれてるんだから
その業がその業のプログラムに子育てプログラムないならば
まあ知ったことないでしょうに
人生を全部死ぬまで管理するのは業だから
だから人に女だからってみんなに子供生まれるわけないんです
これに戦争を持ってくるんですね
たちの悪い戦争ですね
皆様のご先祖様たちが
なんでも放っておかないんですかね
自分たちのもうひひひひ孫たちでしょ
もう放っておけばいいでしょうに
業は区別の説明になりますが
差別を正当化 正当化することはできません
よく覚えてください 業はなぜ世の中
均等でないのかと なぜ同じ両親に生まれる子供が一人一人違うのかと
なぜ一卵性双生児であっても
二人が違う違う道に行くのかと
それが業を説明してあげてるんです
差別しろよとどこから出てくるんですかね
誰でも無始なる過去から輪廻転生しているのです
この輪廻転生というものあるんです
で これも業の説明に必ず関係あるもので
しかし 難しいんですからね
どうやって輪廻転生するのかいっていうことはね
今日はないと思いますけど
書いてないと思いますけど
一応この順番から考えてください
我々は無始なる過去から輪廻転生しているのです
ですから 量的に言えば
皆ほぼ同じ量の悪業も善業も背負っていると推測した方が良いのです
私の業が重い あなたの業が軽いとか
そんなのはありえないんです
輪廻転生から見れば みんな虫なる過去から輪廻転生しているんです
例えばミミズを取ってきて
こいつはかわいそうで業が悪くて
俺なんか人間で業が良くてとか言えたもんじゃないんです
ミミズの業の量も自分の業の量もほとほぼ同じです
善であろうか 悪であろうか
両方 蟻一匹見て なんだこの蟻やとかね
かわいそうで その差別はとんでもないんです
蟻一匹も私と同じ量の業を背負っているんです
善も悪業も まあ善行と悪業で比較すると
悪業の方が誰にしたっても多いかもしれませんよ
一人の人間の生命の悪業と善業
秤に載れば もう悪業の方がドカンと重くて知ってる
善行は少ないかもしれませんだけど
しかし その割り当ては
アリにもミミズにも 我々人間にも
犬にも猫にも全部同じなんです
だから仏教は生命を業という
視野で見てくださいと
生命差別してはいけませんよと
重度の障碍者が自分の家に来たら
障碍者嫌やこれはとか思うところはとんでもない態度なんです
みんな同じ業をほぼ同じ量の業を持っているんだから
観覧車の上にいる人に
下にいる人を見下すことはできないでしょう
で 観覧車に乗って観覧車が回っているんだから
上に行ったら ほら 私は上に
お前下でしょうにと 馬鹿野郎とか
ざまあみろと言える 馬鹿馬鹿しいでしょうに
ざまあみろと言ったっても
どんどん観覧車が下がってきて
あの人上にいるんだから
だから我々は輪廻転生の中では
いろんな寿命が終わったら死ななくちゃあかんでしょうに
人間はもう 80 歳ぐらいだったら
もう死ななくちゃいけないでしょう
それから別な生命になる
それからそこで死んで
また別な生命になる 皆様方
死んで蚊になったら まあ 1 週間も経たないうちに
もう欲張りだからね もういきなり血を吸うするでしょ
もう潰されて死んじゃいます
で それからまた別なところに行く
神にもなる 餓鬼道にも落ちる
地獄にも行く だから地獄にいる生命が本当にかわいそうで
悪人やとか こんなことは言ってはならんですよ
あなたも行きますから
それからと 地獄の時でたっても
その寿命が終わったら
その業が終わったら また亡くなって
なところに行くんですよ
これはもうなんか激しい観覧車ですよ
きれいに円を回っていないだけで
皆同じ円を回っているだけですが
世を見渡すと無知な人に差別意識が生まれる
業を気にする人は皆平等だと知って自分を戒めるんです
一般人が世の中を見て差別を作る
業を気にする人が差別しない
生命を差別しない どんな生命に対しても
ああ こんにちはという態度で接するんです
業は一切の生命は平等である
しかし 生命に個性があるので同一にはならないというメッセージです
はい こういうメッセージですね
はい ここまで話を聞くと
なんか業からは全く抜けられないという
業に抑えられて管理されて身動きできないことになっているという感じになります
だからこの体そのものも業だからね
言っておきますけど まぶた閉じることも業なんです
業の力がなければできません
腰が痛いとかね それも業です
皆さんはもう座っていて
お尻とか痛くなってるでしょ？でも皆そうじゃないでしょ
結局は まあ眠くなってるかって言えばほとんど皆かもしれませんだけど
で そんなもんなんですよ
この人の話を聞くと もう眠くてしょうがないと言われても
皆平等にそうなるのかというと
そうでもないんです ですが
業は絶対者ではありません
今までの説明から 業に敵うものは何もないように見受けられます
しかし 業は絶対的なものではありません
業も無常たる現象です
体の細胞  DNA からすべて業なのに
絶対者ではないんです
業も無常です 業も因縁によって生じる現象です
業も因縁によって生じる現象
他の因 他の条件でなくては
業に結果を出すこともできません
例えば自分の相続業で億万長者になる運命があるとしましょう
座っていたらなると思う？私の業が
調べてみたら 宗教家に来たら
私は億万長者になる業だよと言われてきましたよと
ですから 何もしないで待ってみますと
言ったらどうなるんですかね
どうもな じゃあ占ってみたら
もうあなたには宝くじが当たりますよと
それで 1億をもらいますよ
言ったら当たると思う？当たらないんです
まずは宝くじを買わないと
もう買いたくなければ
誰か買ったものを盗まないと
うまくいかないでしょ？じゃあ人の宝くじを盗んだとしましょう
それで当たったと それで金になる？なりません
そこはどこかに適切な決まっている場所があると思いますけど
そういうところに行って
まああれやこれやとね
資料を書いて いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんです
それでやっと手に入るんです
だから 宝くじの 1 等賞が当たる業があっても
それなりに自分も何かしなくちゃいけないんです
だから業は因縁からは解放されてないんです
それから業って無常だから
宝くじ当たる運命があっても
この時期が終わったら終わりです
もう当たらなくなっちゃうんです
例えば とても美しい方と結婚できる運命があったとしましょう
しかし 若い時はふざけて遊んで
そのうちに全くもなくと遊ぶことばっかりで
それでどんどん年取ってしまえば
もうチャンスがなくなっちゃいますよ
ですから 業にしたっても使用期限というものはあります
この使用期限を過ぎたらもう機能しないんです
有効期限があります 業そのものも無常なんです
業論とは因果説のわずかな一部です
このお釈迦様はわかりにくい
業論 お釈迦様は業論なんか語りませんよ
お釈迦様は因縁を語るんです
仏説は因縁説なんです
業説ではありません しかし
因縁の一部が業なんです
ほんのちょっとの一部なんです
これでは経典でね 人が病気になる原因を 8つ示すところがあります
8番目は業です カンマヴィパーカじゃあバーカ
すべてが業によるものではありません
人が人にいろんな病気になりますよとお釈迦様が言っているところがありまして
そこでいろいろ病気のリストは誰々誰々長いリストが書いてありますよ
その中で最後に 天気 が変化をするとね
もう病気になる あるいは事故とかね
人に殴られるとかね 拷問を受けるとか
そういうことででも人は病気になる
食べ物当たっても病気になる
わざと自分でも意図的に病気になることもあり得ると
その 7つぐらい書いて
7番目に業によっても病気になりますと
この一番治療が効かないのは
業によって病気になる時なんですよ
例えば 自分が鼻炎で悩んでいると慢性的に
その鼻炎というのは大した病気じゃないでしょう
それは業であるならば
薬は効かない 業であるならば
もう別に業の機能を変える別な治療をしなくちゃいけないんです
このアトピーの場合も
結構業が絡んでくる場合があります
で 薬を治療して治せない
医者が何に反応を起こすかと
それだけチェックしてリストを書いてくれます
これこれこれこれ気をつけてくださいと
食べたら死ぬかもしれません
そういう方々は このアトピー引き起こす業との反対の行為をすると
大体業の効き目が消えてしまいます
そうでない限りはもうどうしようもないんです
時々業が病気を起こして死ぬ
死なせるというプログラムある場合はもう治らないんです
で 業に生まれるプログラムがあって
生かせるプログラムがあって
死なせるプログラム  3つ業の仕事ですね
ですから この人はもう癌にして死なせなくちゃいけない
この人は脳出血にして死なせなくちゃいけないとかね
この人は心臓発作で死なせなくちゃいけないとかね
それ業の場合は そういう病気はもう治らないんですね
必ずそれで死にます ですが
今言っているのは 業はまあそう思うほど権力者でもないんです
相当管理していますけど
自分にも憲法があります
因果法則に沿って機能しなくちゃいけないんです
業にも有効期限というものはあります
この期限といったらもう何もできないんです
修行者は業を理解するより
因縁を理解することに励むんです
だから仏教の方々は業を理解してやるぞと思いません
それはこの新しい宗教を作る人々の間活動になっているんですね
頭イカれちゃって 簡単に金儲かる方法を考える方々は
まあ業を派手に出しますけど
仏教は派手に出しません
仏教は因果法則を理解しましょうと修行するんです
はい それからまた 5つの自然法則ということを学んでみましょう
ウトゥビージャニヤモーチャ
カンマダンマニヤマタ
チッタッサチャニヤモーティ
ニャッヤパパンチャニヤマタ
これはアビダンマターアビダンマアビダンマアヴァターナというアビダンマのテキストがありまして
このナーマルーパリチェダというチャプターにある偈なんですね
1自然  2主旨  3業  4法
5心という法則があるという説明があります
この法則っていうのは
どうにもならない ある決まっているパターンで動くんです
それは結局は因果法則なんですけど
因果法則はそう簡単には変わりません
例えば私は今マイクロフォンで喋ってますね
それで同じ音がスピーカーから拡大して聞こえます
時々音が出たり 時々スピーカーからザーッと水が流れたりはしないでしょう
あるいはもう水の代わりに小石がザラザラと流れたりとか
煙が出たりとかしちゃうと皆様大変ですよ
どんな準備すればいいかわからなくなっちゃいますね
しかし これは因縁によって作られた機械なんですよ
それで電気を入れているならば
マイクロフォンで喋るとスピーカーから音が出る
皆様はそれで身を守る方法を知っています
耳栓を持ってきたならば
もう今日は大丈夫なんですね
あのあれ あの雨につけるレインコート
それは持つ必要ないんです
だから これっていうのは法則なんです
スピーカーから音が出るのであって
画像は出ません モニターからは画像は出るのであって
音は出ませんとかね その因果法則によって組み立てると
どんな働きをするのかということはしっかり決めてしまいます
そういうことで 世の中はこの 5つの法則で動いていますと
この自然というのは 第1
この中身は膨大なんですよ
例えば地球の自転やら公転やら
これ自然法則ですね 四季節は自然法則なんです
そこで春が花咲くということは自然法則なんです
宇宙の膨張も自然法則なんです
いろいろ太陽がもう爆破して死にます
新しい太陽が現れてきます
それも自然法則なんです
そこで我々の体も自然法則によってどうしようもなく管理されているんです
どうしようもないんです
それは 季節の変わり目でね
風邪引いたり 春になってくるとね
まあ何でしたっけ？花粉症になったり
まあどうしようもないんですね
秋になってくると食欲が出たり
冬はなかなかそんな食欲がなくなったりとかね
それは業ではないんです
自然法則 これで種子っていうのはもう種っていうことですね
だからかぼちゃの種を植えたらもうかぼちゃしか出てこないんですよ
まあトウモロコシも食べたいんだけど
全然出てこないんですね
だからかぼちゃの種が芽が出てツルになって
どんな風に成長して どんな形の花が咲くのか
どんな程度のかぼちゃになるのかとか
そこで種の法則によって決めます
人間の場合も 私は自分の業を持ってきて生まれたんだとかでしゃばっても
やっぱり種はね 両親からもらったんだからね
遺伝子は そこで遺伝子は遺伝子のプログラムで動いているんです
だから 2番目は遺伝子も入ります
4番目は法の法則ということで
法の法則はすべて因縁で変化することであって
一切は無常である 無我である
空であるということですね
法の法則は また その中にいくつかあります
プラスアルファで ブッダの人間にわからないいくつか特色たくさんあります
それも法の法則と言うんです
それから心にも心の法則があるんです
例えば ギャーッと号泣して泣いている人に瞬時に笑うことはできないんです
号泣が収めてなくなって
それから落ち着いて それから何もわからない状態にいて
それからゆっくりと笑うんです
いきなり変えることはできないんです
そのように心にも心の法則があります
それから この 3番目は業の法則ですね
業もまた法則です だから存在すべて
この 5つの法則によって変化しているんであって
そこで誰かがいないんです
管理者がいないんです
全生命 全宇宙の中にあるのは法則のみなんです
地球は自転するんだけど
自転させるバカがいないんです
地球が公転するんだけど
公転させるアホがいないんです
そういうアホがいると
西洋の方々は我々には力説するんです
私にも言われている 言われたんだからね
あなた方は良いことをしたら良い結果になると言ってるでしょ
でも誰かがいなかったら
どうやって良い結果が得られるんですかと
私は返事しなかったんで
相当アホで この人々にはもう真理知るためにはもう 100億ぐらいかかる
8億年ぐらいかかるだろうと思って
もうはい さようならって
そこで対話終わるんです
この連中言うのは 例えば石を空に投げたら落ちますよ
それはわかりますけど
誰が落とすのかい？と聞くんです
どれほどアホかというと
ラジオがあっても人間がスイッチ入れないと聞こえないでしょ
テレビがあっても人間がスイッチ入れないと
車があっても人間が運転しなきゃ動かないでしょ
そこを見て それが宇宙の法則にしてやろうと思ってるんです
ですから これはすごい難しいポイントなんですね
この一質の法則ということは
物事は変化して流れるパターンのことで
だから法則っていうのは
どのように物事は変化して流れるのかと
例えば私の DNA の中で
このがんになる DNA ね
DNA が入っているならば
その時期になってくるとがんが発生するんです
だから法則を知ったらなんとか手加えられますよ
例えば DNA を遺伝子を改良する
このがんを作る遺伝子を変えて別な遺伝子にするとかね
これは可能です 業だけに勝手に独立して行動することはできません
そこで私が言いたい結論は
業は一人勝手で動いて動いて動いてやるぞと思っても無理
業の自然法則に従わなくちゃいけない
種子の法則に従わなくちゃいけない
心の法則に従わなくちゃいけない
法の法則に従わなくちゃいけないんです
だからみんなそういう憲法をちゃんと守って活動動いています
はい これでぐるっと変わります
セクションは  業の話はだいたいそこら辺で終わりと思ってください
で 別な側面に入ります
チェータナ 業によって生まれても
生きる場合は意思という判断が必要です
業によって生まれても
それから生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
この生きているために意思が必要なんです
チェータナが必要なんです
意思も決して完全自由ということはないが
判断しなくては何にもなりません
自由意志は存在しないんです
しかし 意思がないと何もなりません
ですから 業に完璧にすべてを決定
決定することも定めておくこともできません
運命は成り立ちません
そこで私たち 生まれるときは
この体を持ちますね 赤ちゃんが
これ 赤ちゃんにはこんな体嫌やっていうことはできません
赤ちゃんはどんな体で生まれるかっていうことは
業がやるんです 業が赤ちゃんの体を作るんだけど
業もやっぱりハンディがありますよ
この子はすごい健康的な
すごい体格のいい子供にしてやろうかなと思っても
業はあるんですよ 力が
あるんだけど 遺伝子に従わなくちゃいけないんです
だから 遺伝子が許す範囲で健康な格好いい人間にするんです
そこで遺伝子が許す だっても生まれてる環境が
例えばエチオピアで生まれたとしましょう
で 赤道の真下なんですね
そんなに体大きくならないんです
色も変わるんです だから我々の体の大きさも
地球のどこに生まれたか
どこに大きくなるのかということによっても変わります
だから私たちは基本的に南ですから
地球の引力は結構あるところなんですよ
だから比較的に体が小さいんです
だからといって遺伝子もありますからね
遺伝子が背を伸ばしちゃうと
まあそれも伸びます そういう
そういうところでなんとか折り合いなんです
はい そこはもう置いておいて
チェータナって何なのかと
赤ちゃんが自分でおっぱいをパクパクと吸わないと
自分で泣かないと 赤ちゃんが自分で泣くと
お母さんがもう心配しちゃって
おっぱいが出るんです
だから赤ちゃんはそれなりに頑張らないと
笑ったり泣いたり お母さんの髪の毛を引っ張ったり
おっぱいを噛んでみたり
いろんなことをやっているんです
そのやることによってお母さんに愛情が出てきて
まあ赤ちゃんを育てます
だから赤ちゃんも意思がなくなっちゃうと
もう生命は成り立ちません
ですから このすべて決まっているわけじゃないんです
個人がチェータナという舵を操作しなくてはいけないんです
業がいろんな体を作ってくれますけど
私たちにもうスイッチを上げているんです
意思という そこで我々は意思で行動するんです
歩いたり 座ったり 喋ったり
勉強したり ご飯食べたり
寝たり起きたりするのは自分の意思でやっているんです
水を飲んだり 本を読んだり
どんな本を読むのかと選んだり
自分の意思でやっています
例えば 歴史書に興味が出るのか
文学本に興味が出るのかということは
もしかすると業が決めているかもしれませんよ
しかし 自分がその本を選んで
例えば歴史に興味ある人間が生まれてしましょう
歴史に興味あるということは業なんですね
では 歴史学者になりますか？なりません
そこで その人が自分で歴史書を探して
読んで調べて知識人にならなくちゃいけないんです
業が音楽の才能ある体を作るかもしれません
では 自動的に音楽家になりますか？なりません
本人が自分の意思で あ
これは面白い もう練習しなくちゃとかね
自分が練習して練習して
音楽の道を歩まなくちゃいけないんです
その場合は あの五 五つの法則の自然というものも働きます
例えば ものすごい抜群に音楽の才能ある人が私の国に生まれたとしましょう
その人は音楽にしたっても
例えば西洋音楽に才能があると
でも 自分の国ではピアノとかまずない
だから環境でまずいんですね
ピアノはないんです インドの楽器ならありますけど
だから買ってくれないと思いますよ
ピアノを買うお金で インドの楽器だったらもうたくさん買えます
オーケストラに必要な楽器はほとんど買えます
だったら何なのかと これはと
こんな単純な音のためにこれぐらい金かかるのかいということでやらないんです
ですから 自分の国 ピアニストになる運命があっても
自分の国に生まれたならば
その業が実らなくなっちゃうんですね
では 皆様聞きたくなる
だったらなんでピアノのある国に生まれないのかというと
業はものすごく複雑だから
そう簡単に国は決められません
だから業にも他のプログラムがありますからね
だから他のプログラムをクリアするためにその場所で生まれるかもしれません
それってよくわからない
たとえ業が良くなくても
舵を操作することで生きる道を変えられます
ですから 私たちは業を気にする必要ないんです
私たちにこの照準環握らせているんだからね
これで自分が自分の人生を正しく
自分好きな方向へ操縦すればよろしいのです
それが業の一番大事なポイントなんです
業そのものが絶対者みたいにすべて支配していますけど
チェータナがないとどうにもならん
ごちそうを食べる運命があっても
自分が自分の意思でその方向へ働かないとごちそうは食べられないんです
このチェータナが仏教がものすごい強烈に持つポイントなんです
そこでお釈迦様がこうおっしゃるんです
チェータナハンビッカレカンマンワダニ
私はチェータナこそが業だと言いますよと
だから我々 この今まで説明した業のセクションはもうあまりもうどうにもならん
だからこれは放っておきなさいと
あなたに大事な業はチェータナだ
意志だよと だから意志が業であると理解しておきなさいと
これで安全ですよと 意志は自分にはいくらでも何でもできますから
やるかやらないか やる前か当たり前でやめるか
とことんやるのかどうかね
自分で自分の意志の管理は完璧にできます
ですから 意志そのものも業であると
はい 次のセクション 行為としての業
業 カンマは行為という意味も
結果という意味もあります
あの業には意味２つです
一つは果報 もう一つは行為
一般の方々はนี้果報ばっかり気にしているんです
だから間違いないところなんです
果報はどうにもならん
分かりづらいものです
頭がイかれてしまいます
だから今まで私は果報の説明をしました
しかし 私たち興味を持つべきなのは行為の業なんです
今まで結果として業の業の説明でした
起きた出来事 起きた結果はそのまま放っておくしかないのです
起きたこと 起きた もう終わったんだから
もう放っておきましょう
もう生まれちゃったんだからね
今更女になりたい 男になりたい
翼が欲しいとか いい加減にしろよと
もうそんなもう意味がないんです
もう結果が出まったから
それからの行為に気をつければいいんです
問題は次の次にどのように意思という舵を操作させて前に進むのかということです
例えば地震が起きて津波が来た
すべて壊れました はい
終わり それで話は 結果が出た
これに泣いたり悩んだり
なんだこりゃと 元に戻れんでしょう
それで簡単なことは 次にあなたはどうするのかということだけ
だから個人個人が果報の業はもうもう無視して放っておくんです
果報の業じゃなくて こうなっちゃったんだからどうしましょうか？という
たったそれだけなんです
いつでも皆様の頭の中に
ではどうしましょうという質問を入れておいてください
ものすごく紛れ込むんです
あー大変だ 大変なことになっちゃった
あ どうしよう どうしようとか
とんでもないバカなんです
どうしようどうしようともわめくんじゃなくて
ではどうしましょう この場合はと
行動的にその質問を働かせるんです
もう私なんかはもうずっとその訓練で癖で何か起きたって全然びっくりしないんです
何か起きてくると 次にどうしましょうかということはもう入っているんです
入って もう行動も全部決めているんです
瞬間に だから悩んだり
落ち込んだり びっくりしたり
怖くなったりする余裕がないんです
次にやるべきことがもう頭に入っているんです
それが業の正しい捉え方だと思います
意思によって新たな行為をすることが業と言えます
ですから 自分の意思で新たな行為をする
津波で地震で日本の3分の1が壊れちゃったら
ではまずこれをやるべき
次にこれをやるべき 次にこれをやるべきです
それだけなんです 動いてないでしょ
いまだに ただ 人間がもう本当にもう苦しんだ時
もう食べるものもなくて
その時はみんなさあさあって言って協力してあげたんですけど
それからはドカーンともう何もないという
だからこのどんな被害を受けた人も
他の人で みんなもいつでも我々ははい
次にどうしましょう？次のステップは何なのかという生き方で
行為に徹して生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
アクティブに徹しなくちゃいかないんですよ
常に我々はアクティブでなくてはいけない
アクティブというのは活発で
2 重も悩んだらダメなんです
なぜならば 悩むことは行為なんです
美しくないんです 人が死んだら悲しむでしょう
あれも行為なんです しかし
悪行為です 親戚が亡くなったと
もう落ち込んで悲しくてしょうがないと
これは美しいことじゃないんです
優しさでもないんです
悪行為なんです だからいつでもどうすれば良いということを頭に入れて
すぐアクティブで行動に行かなくちゃいけないんです
それは行為なので また条件が揃ったら果報になります
それから私たちは意志でやっているすべての行為が業ですから
結果出します だから一旦悪い結果になっても
それからアクティブに生きてみると
良い結果にすることができます
だから どんな不幸も我々の意志次第で幸福の起爆剤にすることはできます
逆もできます 幸福の結果を不幸の起爆剤にするという
みんなそれをやっているみたいんですけど
仏教はもう何があっても自分の意志でそれは好転させなさいよと
目がなくて生まれた 別にどうってことないでしょう
目がないことは意志を使って有効に使う
耳が聞こえない体で生まれたら別に構わない
ではどうしましょうかと
ではこういうこういうことならできそうやと
日本でも誰かさんがいたでしょうね
一人二人ぐらい もう体全部もう筋肉なんとかの病気で動かないんだけど
やっと足だけでなんか筆をとって
それでも絵を描いたりして
時々口で筆をとって絵を描いたりしたりとかね
これまたいい作品できてるんですよ
だから 普通の人を描くものよりは
そちらにみんなの心が惹かれてしまいますよ
だから この 幸福か不幸かということはあまり関係ないんですね
人間にとっては それに引っかかると暗いんです
悪行為になります 私は幸福ですとか思ったら
もう傲慢になって悪行為になる
私は不幸やと思ったら
もう怒りで落ち込んで暗くなって
もう悪行為になりますね
だからそれじゃなくて
やっぱりどうしましょうかということで
次々次 意志を持って良い行為をすることですね
人生っていうのは どのように生きるのかということは大事です
なんで生まれたのかではないんです
なぜ生まれたのかではないんです
どのように生きるのかと
もう生まれちゃったんだから
もうどうしようもないでしょ
今更なんで生まれたのかと聞いたってね
時間の無駄です もう逆戻りできないでしょう
だったらどう生きるのかということでしょう
ちょっと難しくなります
感覚とこう感覚ヴェーダナの流れが生きることなのです
これちょうど難しいんです
この生きるということは
我々の体に感覚があって
感覚が流れるんです 見える
聞こえる 考える 感じる
寒くなる 暖かくなる 体が痛くなる
楽になるとか感覚がありますよ
これが生きることなんですよ
例えばお腹が空いたということは感覚です
それでご飯を食べる 感覚があるんだからご飯を食べる
満腹になることは感覚です
それでご飯食べることをやめる
呼吸もするのは感覚があるんだからなんです
感覚がなくなると呼吸もできなくなります
ですから感覚が生きていることであって
感覚が本当の命にもなります
感覚の停止は生命の死です
感覚が隙間なく変化することは
また法則です 心の法則です
隙間なく変化する ですから
この世で死んでも感覚が繋がりますので
再び生まれる羽目になります
法則を一にする中で 心の法則というものがありました
心の法則の一つは 隙間なく現れる
心が瞬間で消えますが
隙間なく次の心が現れる
感覚というのは心のことです
ですから 心が感覚が停止したら死にますけど
隙間なく現れます これはもうストップできません
ですから 人が死んでも
この肉体の中で感覚が停止しても
感覚そのものが隙間なくまた回転するんです
そこはもう再生したと言うんです
生死の流れだ あるいは感覚の流れですね
今も起きている 死後も続くんです
今も我々は死んで生まれて
死んで生まれているんです
それは時々足がなくなったりね
目が見えなくなったり
いろいろ故障が起きますけど
最終的にはこの肉体という機械そのものが故障して機能しないことになります
しかし 死んで生まれる流れは止まりません
死んでば生まれる 死んで生まれるという流れは感覚の流れなんです
だから体が壊れても感覚が無常で変化して続けるんです
苦楽 不苦不楽という 3種類の感覚を認識できます
私たちには感覚というのは 3つに分けられます
苦の感覚 楽の感覚 不苦不楽の感覚という
意志により起こす行為は
苦の感覚を引き起こすならば
その果報として苦が生じるのです
楽 不苦不楽の場合も同じです
これポイントは難しいんです
私たちは歩くということはどういうことですかね
感覚を変化することです
座っていると何か感覚があるんですよ
その感覚は苦で嫌で じゃあちょっと歩きましょうと
と歩くんです 歩くときは感覚は変化するんです
ですから 行為とは感覚の変化なんです
それで私が行為すると苦しみの感覚を引き起こす
それが悪行為というんです
なぜならば 悪結果で苦しみの感覚になるんだから
楽の感覚生まれる行為すれば
これはもう人間好きですね
それは 具体的に言えば
他人を助けたり 悩みがなくすようにしてあげたりすることは
他人に楽の感覚を与えることです
例えば 私が人を助ける
人の悩みをなくしてあげる
何したんですかね あの相手の苦の感覚を楽な感覚に変えさせたんです
泣くんじゃなくて笑っちゃえ
笑っちゃえとかね こんなのはね
もう気にすることないでしょうとかね
なんとかして人の悩みをなくしてあげる
それで私は相手の苦しみの感覚を楽しい感覚に変えたんです
これ私がやったんです
そこで その果報として私も楽しい感覚を得られます
自分の意志が起こしたその行為は
自分に楽を与える力のある業になるんです
だから 果報として私も楽になります
一般人がそれに善行為というんです
仏教の精密的な定義で言えば
あまり善行為 悪行為という定義って成り立つかどうかわからないんだけど
まあ楽の感覚を引き起こす行為は
まあ一応善行為にします
苦しみは嫌だから 苦しみの感覚を起こす行為は悪行為にします
例えば私は犬を殺す 犬に何あげたんですかね
最大の恐怖感 最大の苦しみ与えたんです
最大の悩みを与えたんです
だったら自分も見事にその結果
その感覚を受けます だから業が弱いんだから
このいろいろ条件が揃ってないと結果が出ないだけ
結果が出ます とにかく条件が揃うまで待ってます
1万寄付したら  10万寄付したら結果はとね
みんな結構それ気にするんですね
と気になりますが 答えはわかりませんよ
1万円の寄付の功徳が高いか
10万円の功徳寄付の功徳が高いか
こんなにわかる こんなのわかりません
他にどの程度の幸福 楽
喜び 安心感を与えたのかで結果は設定されます
私はどの程度に幸福を与えたのかという
金額じゃないんです 気持ちは数字で計算できません
それから  1万円私のものだから
私に 1万円に対する愛着があります
そこでもう一人が 10万円持っていて
その人に 10万円の愛着があります
しかし このあげる場合は愛着をなくさなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからこの愛着は計算できないんですね
例えば 私に 1万円しかないならば
私には強烈な愛着があります
10万円持っている人にとっては
もう銀行にね 例えば 3000万円もあります
だったら 10万円に対する愛着が少ないんです
そこで二人であげましょうとあげると
私は最大の力のある愛着をなくしてるんです
相当大変なことをやってます
しかし この 3000万円持っている人が 10万円どうしようと痛みも快感もなく
痛みも快感もなくあげてるんですね
だから このなくした愛着ので計算しなくちゃいけないんです
業の結果は みんなこの客観的にこの金で計算しようと思ってるんだからね
これはもう正しくないんです
意志と感情 感情が意志に判断を促します
感情を参考にして判断します
もう4時は過ぎましたけど
休憩にしますかね で あの
我々は業を持って生まれるんですね
すべて業が体そのものから髪の毛 1本まで全部業なんですね
もうこれどうしようもない
しかし 私たちは生きる時は自分の意志だけ使わなくちゃいけない
たったできるのはそれだけなんです
意志もそれほど自由がないんです
意志って判断します ご飯食べますと判断します
で ご飯食べますけど サンドイッチにしますと自分が判断します
だからサンドイッチにするか何にするかという
そこで条件によって 例えばもうご飯を食べたくないという気持ちがあって
それだったらサンドイッチでいいんじゃないかという風になったりするんですからね
とにかく この判断するときは何か参考にしなくちゃいけないんですね
この参考にするものが感情というんです
気持ちですね なんであなたはおにぎりもあるし
ラーメンもあるし サンドイッチもあるんだけど
なんでサンドイッチに決めたんですか？と聞いてもよくわからないでしょ
ただ 気持ちですね  そんな気持ちですよと
そういうことで 我々は判断するとき
意志を働かすとき いつでも感情を参考にするんです
これがかなりやばいんです
だから仏教ははこのチェータナーに気をつけろよと
意志に気をつけろよと
理性で判断しないんです
貪瞋痴は柱になる感情です
この衝動で起こす行為は
悪結果をもたらす業になります
そこで感情といえば 結局は貪瞋痴です
だから理性で判断しない
ラーメン食べたらカロリーの方がたくさんあるし
いろいろ味もいっぱい入ってるし
だから私はまあこういうこういうわけでサンドイッチにしまったというところまで行ってないんですよ
サンドイッチが好きや
それで終わっちゃいます
そういうことだから この理性で判断するのは正しいんだけど
誰もやってないんです
貪瞋痴で気持ちで判断するんです
これが全部悪行為になります
貪瞋痴を制御するために行う行為のみ善行になります
ですから 気持ちでいくんじゃなくて
この気持ちを抑えようと制御しようとしたことだけは善行為になります
すごい微妙なポイントなんです
貪瞋痴に従うんじゃない
貪瞋痴に従わなくて 貪瞋痴をちょこっとコントロールしようとすることで善行になります
だから  1万円で自分がごちそうを食べても善行になりません
あれは感情で気持ちでやっちゃったんだから悪行為になるんです
1万円が誰かに困っている人にあげると
自分が遊びたかったのに
そこをコントロールしちゃったんです
ごちそうを食べたかったのにコントロールしちゃったんです
それが善行になるんです
仏教の道徳リストは貪瞋痴の制御を狙って解かれたものです
仏教では道徳リストがあります
このリストは貪瞋痴を制御するためにできているんです
貪瞋痴の根絶は究極の善であり
業から解放されることでもあります
それで貪瞋痴を根絶しちゃうと
もう業から初めて自由です
もうあやそれませんということになるんです
はい 次 最後のセクション
悪業から悪業の果報から身を守る
例えば不自由な体に生まれたら
それは業がガタガタということなんです
人間には悪業で生まれるということはないんです
人間みんな良い業で生まれるんです
が 良いというところにも差があるんだからね
金はいいんだけど まあまあ金がない場合は金メッキにするでしょう
だから金メッキと金の差が結構ありますよ
全く金で見えますけどね
そんな感じで人間は善行で生まれますけど
この善行にも差があります
そこでこの 自分が悪業から身を守った方がとにかくいいんです
日々大量に善行を行う
善行になる業を貯めていく
毎日毎日良いこと 良いこと
良いことや貪瞋痴に反対のことをやってやって
もうたくさん貯めるんです
なんかいいことをする
いつでもいいことをして貯めるんです
善行為で忙しいので 果報としての過去の業に結果を出すチャンスがなくなります
ですから 例えば私がとんでもない不幸になる運命であったとしましょう
プログラムで でも私は良いことをすることに忙しいんです
忙しいんだから あの業にちょっとチャンスがないんです
はい 時々私の体もね かなりきつく痛くなって倒れそうになる時もありますよ
その時 講演とか何とかある場合は
講演中はないんです その痛みは
なぜかというと 頭忙しいんです
仏教のことを考えることで
だから体を痛めつけてやるぞという業は
じゃあちょっと待ってみましょうと
待ってる間でこの有効期限切れる時もあります
だからそういうことですから
降ってくる 降りてくる悪業があっても
私たちは善行為することで忙しいんだったら結構逃げられます
悪いことから 現在の善業の加法力も心に溜まるので
過去の悪行為の順番が下がってしまうこともあります
それから 過去の悪業が加法打算しているんです
順番で待ってるんです
待ってるんだけど 私は毎日善行為しているんだから
そちらにも加法のパワーがあるんですよ
そちらが先の順番取っちゃったらどうしますか？あの過去の方がもうちょっと下がる羽目になるんです
そうやって順番下げてもらうこともできます
怒り 欲 嫉妬 恨み 憎しみ
悩み 落ち込みなどの感情をなくしてみる
その妄想をやめる もう怒り憎しみはさようなら
やらんと決めるんです
怒らない 悩まないよと
何があってもニコッと笑って生きてみるぞと言うと
結構悪業がもう化けなくなっちゃうんです
毎日すごい笑って優しい人間でいれば
もう好転してしまいますよ
それでも悪業から自分を守られます
で 悪の果報を現すあらわにする意志が弱くなってしまう
それでこの意志が弱くなっていくんですね
悪いことをしたいと意志があるんです
して ひどい目になりたいという意志があるんだけど
もう怒らない 悩まない
悔やまないということにしたら
もう悪業がもう下がっちゃいます
順番が はい  2番目の方法
日々慈悲の慈悲喜捨の念を修行する
善行為は何かよくわからないんだけど
とりあえず慈悲喜捨でもやりますと
慈悲喜捨の念を頭に入れておくんです
他の妄想をやめるんです
頭の中で慈悲喜捨だけにするんです
何が起きても慈悲の念を忘れないようにする
一切の行為は自動的に善行為に変わってしまうんです
それで慈悲喜捨の念で生きていると
何やっても善行為なんですよ
慈悲喜捨がない人は困らなくちゃいかんですね
いいことをしたいんだけど
どうしたらいいでしょうかとかね
しかし 慈悲喜捨の念がある人にとっては別に大丈夫です
やることは何でも善になっちゃいます
だからそこはすごい便利なんです
善行為に悩んで悩んで善行為を決める人と違います
すごい楽なんです 大胆な過去の悪業でない限り
過去の悪業が実るチャンスが失うんです
この慈悲喜捨でいると
悪業はなかなか出番がなくなるんです
たとえ障害を持って生まれても
慈悲喜捨で生きてみると
体が障害を持っているんだから不幸になるはずですけど
このチャンスがないんです
それでごく普通に明るく生きていられて
生きていられてしまいます
ですから この不幸を避けるからくりっていうのは慈悲喜捨の念なんです
あの祈祷じゃないんです
過去の業の善行だけ結果を出す羽目になるんです
慈悲喜捨でいると 過去の悪行為もあるし
善行為もありますけど
善行為だけもうどんどんどんどん出てくるんです
慈悲喜捨の念は 過去の悪業にも大きなダメージを与えるんです
もう一つありますよ 慈悲喜捨を念じれば念じるほど
過去の悪業が結構ダメージを受けるんです
ダメージを受けちゃうと
結果出す順番になってももうガタガタでできないんです
だから過去の悪業を壊すこともできます
慈悲喜捨で また またあります
妄想をやめる 妄想を制御する実践を
実践は最上の善行為です
この妄想するということは
感情をかき回すことです
いわゆる悪です とんでもない悪ですよ
妄想することは ですから
妄想を停止することが最上の善行為なんです
妄想を停止しようとする力は相当強いです
妄想をストップさせよう
ストップさせようとする
この力がものすごいパワーなんです
だからこれ善行為なんです
今世で起こる予定の悪結果はほとんどなくなります
だから生まれたら 自分には不幸になるプログラムもあるし
幸福になるプログラムもねじ混じってありますよ
妄想をやめようとすると
不幸になるプログラムがほとんどもう実行不可能状態になるんです
意志がとても強くなります
例えば ヴィパッサナー瞑想とか始める人々はよく言うことをですね
なんか人生はようわからないんだけど
なんかうまく今なってるんだと
次から次へと問題もなんか自分も何もやってないのは消えてるんだと
これはどういうことか
先生と言っても私は説明しないんです
こういうことなんです
真面目に実況中継で妄想をストップすると
この自分にかかってくる予定であった悪が実行不可能状態になっているんです
理性が現れますよ 妄想をやめると
妄想をやめたら何しますかね？論理的な物事しか考えられないでしょ
だから理性が出てくるんです
理性は善です 理性が現れたら
生きる道は悪から離れて善の流れに入るんです
それから今 我々は悪の道で生きているんです
貪瞋痴で生きているんだから
一日生きたら一日分いっぱい悪いことをしたことになります
100年生きたらね  100年間も相当悪いことをしたことになります
ろくなことじゃないんで
生きることは とんでもない悪いことなんです
それで妄想をやめるとどうなるかというと
この悪を犯す道からガクーンと変わって
脱線して善の道に人生が入れ替えられます
これすごい便利なことなんです
それ  4番目は智慧を育てる
ブッダの語られた真理を学ぶことで
理解することで まずは理性
智慧発見するためには
アインシュタインの本を読んでも無知になるだけ
科学者の本は読むほど無知になりますよ
欲がどんどん現れてくるんです
だから世の中の学問を学んでも
智慧は現れません 欲ならいくらでも現れます
ですから 智慧が現れて欲しければ
ブッダに説かれた真理を学ぶなくちゃいけない
それはもう決定的で断定的でどうしようもないんです
聖書を読んだっても とんでもない人になるだけ
寂しさに悩まされるすごい悪い人間になるんです
人を殺しても構わないだろうという気分にもなります
ですから ブッダの教えを学ぶしかないんです
他ヒンドゥー教を学んだっても
ヨーガスートラサーストラ読んでも
バガヴァッドギーター読んでもダメです
全部 この聖書という書類は人に悪を促しているテキストですよ
心理学的に微妙に良くないんです
今私が言った のも高等な心理学ですけど
ものすごい難しいんですから
もう今飛ばしているところで
ですから 智慧開発したければ
ブッダの教えを学ぶことはもうしょうがないんです
学んでいくと理性が現れますね
まず真理に納得すること
智慧が現れるようになります
こととそれからブッダが教えたことを考えていくと
いや なるほど その通りやと
ああ よくわかった この通りだとわかってくると
納得いくとも智慧が現れ出すんです
こう 無常無我な話は智慧を引き起こすんです
だから 空ってなんですか？無我ってなんですか？無常と何ですか？とか
それは実験しながら学んでいくと
結構智慧が起きてきます
因縁を理解することも智慧と言います
あれは空無常無我ではなくて
因縁とは何かと学ぶと
まあ智慧が現れます 八正道の実践は智慧に達する方法です
智慧を経験したければ
八正道という方法がありまして
それを実践するんです
智慧が現れたら一切の執着がなくなります
解脱に達することは 業から完全に解放されることです
業っていうのは 善であろうが悪であろうか
とんでもない悪いんですよ
ですから これから逃げなくちゃいかんですよ
逃げる方法っていうのは智慧を開発することなんですね
智慧を開発して執着なくなる
なくなるんですね 生きていきたいという執着も業になります
これなくなったら まあ業からの解放で解脱と言うんです
一応これで話は終わると思います
さらに知りたいことがありますならば
これで今日の話はこれで終了いたします
スマナサーラ先生 どうもありがとうございました
すぐに質疑応答の方に入らせていただいてよろしいでしょうか
それでは会場からいただきました質問をいくつか読み上げて
スマナサーラ先生にお答えいただきたいと思います
いただいた質問の中には
瞑想に関する質問とかですね
あるいは偶然ですけど
来月の 12月の月例講演会で取り扱うテーマに関する質問などもありました
そういうものに関しましてはちょっと割愛させていただきました
瞑想に関してはですね
次号のパティパタ 12月号で瞑想に関する質問
質疑応答を集めた特集が組んでありますので
そういうものも参考になるかと思いますので
ぜひお楽しみください
今回は先ほどの講演の内容に沿った質問をいくつかピックアップしてみました
一つ  40代の女性の方からの質問です
今 私だと思っているこの業は
今生が終わって来世に転生するときには
他の生命の業と混ざったり
いくつかに混ざっていくつかに分かれたりすることはあるのでしょうか
補足で もし蚊に生まれ変わるとしたら
何匹かに分かれたり 何人か分の業が合わさって大きな生き物になったりとか
そういうことはありますか？という質問です
それはあの 大体仏教の立場から言えば
これは全くないんですね
分離はしません うーん
あの なんかあのリトルブッダというね
もうアメリカ人かイギリス人が作ったね
あの変な映画がありまして
このチベットの生まれ変わる論理ですね
これで魂が 3つに分離するんだぞとかね
あれはまあ政治的なインチキで
現実はそれ違います それで誰かさんが生まれ変わって
一人はアメリカ人になければ商売にならない
ですから 死んだ人の一人がアメリカ人の子供に生まれて
もうインドで映画を撮影するんだから
もう一人インド人の子供を雇わないとね
で それからまあ 監督はイギリス人だからね
おそらくイギリス人も一人いたでしょうかね
そういう感じにも魂を分離されてますけどね
そういう映画なんかの話に値しないんです
で 私という今の業の塊もいろんなものを組み立ててできているんです
だから今の体もずっと変わって変わっていくんです
だから 生まれた時の肉体は今とっくにないんですね
だから細胞やら遺伝子やらね
もう 3ヶ月間程度で もうほとんど新しいものに変わっていくでしょうに
ですから そのように肉体は変わられて
死んだら肉体捨てますから
地球からもらったものは全部地球に戻すんですね
で 感覚だけは地球からもらったものじゃないんですね
心はね 心も体よりものすごい早く変わって変わって変わっていくんですよ
だから今の瞬間の私が次の瞬間の私じゃないんです
ただ流れ思い出せるんだから
ただ私という言葉を使っているだけで
忘れたらわからないんですね
人間にも時々記憶喪失という問題があって
これはかなり重度に犯してしまったら
犯されてしまったら 自分の名前まで忘れてしまうんですよ
である 日本の男性が何かの治療ミスで脳の記録するところが壊れちゃって
で  2 3分のデータしか残らないんですね
ですから全部忘れるんです
で 人と喋る場合は いつでも相手が紹介していかないと誰かとわからないんです
この人のことをビデオで録画してあって
テレビで見たんですけど
スタッフが何日間も作っているんですけど
朝来たらまたみんな一人一人紹介するんです
毎回毎回 それでやっとその人に覚えられるのは
自分の奥さんのことは紹介しなくても
なんとなく奥さんだと知っている
それから子供 2人がいるんですけど
子供 2人のこともなんとなく自分の子供だとわかっている
だからすごい なんか体見るとなんか穏やかで
何の悩みもなくて とっても美しい体でしたけど
だって過去がないでしょ
で 時々奥さんがね なんとか復活してほしいんだから
いろいろ仕事を頼んだり
買い物に行かせたりしますけど
やっぱりリスト書いて子供と一緒に行かなきゃできないんですね
行ったら店に行ったらそれからリスト見るべきやっていうことを子供に言わなくちゃいけないけど
忘れているんです だから
その場合も本人がそれしか覚えていない
自分に過去があったか
子供の頃どうなったか
全部忘れているんですね
そういうことだから 私たちは私
私というのはもうただ
ほんのちょっとのことを覚えているからだけなんですね
この覚えるものというのは至って簡単に忘れちゃいますね
もし記憶力がものすごい強いんだったら
過去はこうでしたと言えるはずなんです
ですから このよく知らないんですね
我々は死んだらどこに行くか
これは私やということはね
特に私という単語が怪しいんですね
それが存在しないんですね
そういうところで 一般の方々には輪廻転生というのはすごい理解しにくくなっています
私が生まれ変わるのかと聞くんですから
この私がって何時何分の私ですかと聞けたら
ですね 今の私が生まれ変われば
次の私になりますからね
それはよく覚えていますね
物質も全部変わったんだけど
ですから この死ぬ時でも
その時の自分が次の瞬間に変化してしまいます
だから物質も全部変わりますから
ドカーンともう差がすごい激しいんだからね
大体は忘れます で 過去を忘れるのもこの執着のことで
この生きることに執着しないと生きていられないんですよ
もし私たちは生まれた時の苦しみを覚えているならば
もう生きていられないんです
生まれる時はすごい苦しくなるんです
すぐそれケロッと忘れちゃいますよ
我々もあの 大体都合の悪いことは忘れるでしょ
都合の悪いことを覚えていても
もう生きていられないんですよ
だから私たちは何を覚えているのかというと
自分の都合のいいところだけ覚えてますから
正しい記憶じゃないんですね
勉強したものでもほとんど忘れて
一部だけ残ってますね
残っているところは自分の都合によって必要なもので
必要でないものは全部綺麗に忘れてしまいます
まあまあ そんな人生ですから
今の私と次の私はもう結局は違います
すっごく違います この流れに輪廻というんですね
これ 私たちはこの 川の流れでよく説明できると思いますね
隅田川ありますかといえば
まああるでしょうね ある立場から見れば
では実質的に隅田川って何でしょうかというと
そんなのあるわけじゃないんですね
ただ 溝があって そこで水が流れているだけに
ですから  1 秒ちょっと隅田川見たらまた見えません
それで別な川なんですね
全部変わってるんですね
それでもなんとなく これは隅田川で
これはもうもう 300年
400年 もう 1000年前からもありましたよとへっちゃらで言うんだけど
これはもう言葉上のことであって
実質的にそういうことではありませんね
我々の命もそういうもので
川のように激しく流れるもので
言葉上私と言うだけなんですね
だから言葉上 私が生まれ変わるのかというと
まあそうだろうと言うしかないんです
現実的にどうなるのかというと
まあ変化し続けるだけですよというしかないんです
それで分離はしないんです
肉体は分離します そこで我々の感覚っていうのは
物質によって感覚の強度やら範囲やら変わるんです
で コウモリになったら
聴覚の範囲がかなり広くなるんですね
あれ 物質によって心の働きが変わるんです
犬になったら臭覚の方が幅がすごく広くなってしまいます
そんなことで 蚊になったらまあその程度でしょうね
よくわからないんですよ
そこで私がある日 皆様は一般的に蚊を馬鹿にしているでしょう
私は馬鹿にしないんですよ
蚊は で 国で自分の国は暑いんだからね
1 年中蚊がいるんですね
そこで私はあえて蚊に対してすごい体が拒絶反応を起こすんです 1
匹の蚊にでも刺されたら
もう朝まで寝られないんです
すっごいもう体が痛くなって痒くなって大変です
だからまあどうしても蚊に刺されたくないよう
刺されないように工夫します
そこで逆に 10人ぐらい人がいるところに蚊が1匹来たら
私を刺すんです この間
どこかで日本でね どこかに行って
高速道路でパーキングで止まってたんですけど
それは夏 暑い日でしたから
で 藪からたくさん蚊が来ていたんですね
で 我々4人がいたんですけど
私がなんか調子おかしいなと見たら
上見たら私の頭の上にでっかい蚊柱が出ているんです
他の 3 人は何やと これ不公平やと思ったんですけど
なんで私だけにやっているのかと
だからおそらく蚊から見れば
私の血をよりおいしく感じるでしょうね
そこで私の体から見れば
蚊の唾液はものすごい拒絶反応を起こす
それで私が自分のベッドに蚊帳がありますからね
蚊帳をつけて寝ているんですね
それ楽しいんですよ 蚊がいっぱい来て
蚊帳に止まっていてね
自分がライトをつけてスタンライトをつけて本を読んでいるんでね
見ると蚊がいっぱいいて
ほら 邪魔見るのと  笑 それで
ちょっと時間経つと中に抱えるんですね
どうやって来たんですかと
そこで調べたら形がもう入らないでしょ
みんなまず床の上に止まるんですね
止まって歩いてくるんです
歩いてきて カニ この上がっているところから歩いて
これから歩いて登るんです
これ見たらもうびっくりしたんですよ
ここまで考えるのかと
どうやってその知恵が入るのかね
ここで私がまたもう起きて
もう蚊帳を全く繰り返して
もう全部出して またもう入らないようにして
ベッドのマットレスにものすごく厳しくつけてつけてつけてつけて
じゃあ今度はどうするのかいと
今度もね 体がどこか触れたらネットにもう即させてるんです
そういうことだから もうなかなか馬鹿にすることできないなと
だからこの生命の心はね
まあ肉体によって制限されますけど
まあびっしり働いてはいるんですよ
我々はいろいろ実験はまあそうやって生命とね
まあ実験してもいたんですけど
やっぱりあの どんな小さな動物でも大事にするのと
すごい気分がいい 対等で扱うとすごく気分がいいんです
で この動物たちのいろいろ生きる時の大変とか悩みとかね
それ感じてしゃべると
すごくもう向こうはすごい態度がいいんですよ
向こうに喋れないんだけど
いろんな方法で自分の悩みを訴えたりするんですね
悲しくなったりもしますけどね
ですから この まああのカニは生まれ変わらないでください
寿命短いしね あまり面白くないしね
で もっと良いことをしてね
もっと人間よりできればね
高い次元に生まれ変わった方がいいと思いますけど
もうでも知ったことがないんだから
どうなるのかと まあ一応答えは分離はしません
心は 1個しかない 心には分離することはできないんです
感覚の差は体によっては起こります
それだけです はい  ありがとうございます
次なんですが 講演の中でアトピー性皮膚炎について講演中お話がありましたが
業の反対をすれば治るということについて教えてほしい
このアトピーの場合は
このその人がおそらくね
私になかったんだからよくわからないんだけど
おそらく私の推測ですけど 2
種類の苦しみがあるんですね
一つは体から出てくる苦しみですね
すごく痒くなったり いらだちがあったりしてね
もう一つは食べたいんだけど食べられない
その苦しみもあるかもしれない
例えば 体には大したことはないんだけど
かゆみも何もないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりこれこれ食べちゃうと
もう大変なことになって死んでしまうとか
アメリカでな 若者がね
ピーナッツと女の子とキスしただけで
若い二人が それだけで女の子は死んじゃったんですね
男が家出る前にピーナッツバター入れてサンドイッチ食べてきたんだから
微妙なところ ちょっと唇に入っていて
キスしただけで 女の子がもう突然病気になって死んでしまったっていうね
だから体に何も問題なかったでしょ
しかし その場合はいろんな
例えばご飯食べられない病気もありますね
日本で考えてみてください
もう結構美味しいご飯
いろんなものあるんですけど
全く食べられなくなっちゃうんですね
それから小麦粉がアレルギーになってくると
もういっぱいケーキやらね
パンやらあるのに もううどんも食べられないし
ラーメンも食べられないし
もう何も食べられなくなっちゃいますね
そういうことで その苦しみはあるかもしれません
そこで我々は反対の業を考える場合は
その本人がどこでどのように苦しんでいるのかと
まず調べなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば 痒くてたまらなくて
そこはイライラしているか
あるいはあれも食べたい
これも食べたいんですけど
食べられないということで苦しんでいるかどうかね
その苦しみを受ける側を見て
そこで業を計算するんですね
例えば 皮膚が苦しんでいる場合は
これは感覚 観測ですね
嫌な観測 体のあの体の観測ですね
体で嫌な観測を 苦しい観測を受けているんですね
その場合は人々に良い観測を与えるんです
まあ例えばね 毛布を寄付するとかね
で 老人ホームにもっと寝やすいと
何て言いますか マットレスを寄付したりとかね
そうやって良い観測を与える
で 例えばね 家が壊れて今あちこちに人々に作ってるでしょ
そういうところで 家を作るために自分もいくらか寄付するとかね
そういう 例えば家一軒作るために
まあいくらかお金寄付しましょう
家ができたところで その人々に良い観測を与えたことになります
そういうふうに この その反対語を行うと
で まあ公園のベンチを全部拭いてあげたりとかね
で そのようにそのいい観測を与えてあげましょうということで
反対語になります で 食べ物の場合はやっぱり同じ
この相手に自分が本当に何が欲しくておいしくて
何食べたいのかと調べて
それ自分でそこを食べられない方々にそういう食べ物を与えたりする
自分食べたいものではなくて
その相手が相手の体に合う
相手がおいしいと感じるものをあげたりする
例えばスリランカでは犬にもお布施をすることあります
もう犬はもう全部放し飼いだからね
あの鎖で縛っておかないんですよ
だからもう誰の犬かわからないんだけど
結構犬たちがいるんですけど
犬たちはちゃんと知ってます
私はあの家 私はこの家とかね
時々仏教の人々は犬にもお布施しようかなと思ったりしてね
で 食べ物をあげたりはします
そこで じゃあ犬に食事を与えようと思ったら
そこら辺にある犬の餌をボーンと出すよりも
このワンちゃんが美味しく何食べるだろうかと思って
すごくおいしくてもうたまらん
ものをあげたりすると
すごいそこで食べるものに対して喜びを感じるんですね
あの向こう側が そういうふうに反対語をすると
自分には食べられるものはやがて何のことなく食べられるんだっていうことになっていくんです
だから 例えばの場合は
この苦しみ どこで苦しみを味わっているのかと調べて
そこで反対を考えるんです
そういうやり方です はい
次の質問です  50代の男性の方なのですが
執着 執着と集中（努力）とはどう違うのでしょうか
執着することと集中することの違い
うーん  それは明らかに違いますから
まあ執着っていうのはね
ポゼッションですね 自分のものにするということだから
だから私のものという気持ちですね
だから まず我々は自分の体に執着する
一番結実 執着は自分の思考に執着する
考えることに で 私たちは私
私と言うのは はっきり言えば自分の思考
ほとんど思考なんですね
で それでこのポゼッシブネス
私のものという風な これは執着です
束縛でもあるしね 行かせてあげないとかね
まあ集中っていうのはこの認識のことで
何か認識するときは雑念がなく
心はあちこち走ることなく
しっかりそれを認識する
あの腕のいい あの 何といいますか
この職人さんたちが仕事をする時はちゃんと執着
集中しているんですね
で 執着があることでも集中できないとは言えませんだけど
これ大した執着集中じゃないんですね
欲しいもの手に入りたくて
もうむちゃくちゃなんとかやる場合はね
まああんまり大した集中力ではないんです
すごいそれによって怒りが出てきたり
頑張ってもあの人は私のものにならなかったというと
かなり怒りが出てきてね
混乱してひどい目に遭うんですね
集中力っていうのは ものすごい充実感を与えてくるんですね
気持ちいいと それから副作用はないんです
集中すると脳がすごく充実感を感じるんだから
体にも肉体的にもすごい
あの 何て言いますか 癒し作用があるんですね
癒してくれるんです だから体がむちゃくちゃ疲れてくると
肉体を癒したければ何かに集中することで集中すると
そこで脳がいろいろ物質を出して体も癒してくれるんですね
だから集中はとてもいいことで
やっぱり欲に絡んでいるものに執着しない方がいいんですね
だから人を助けることで
頭を勉強することに そういうことにね
集中した方がいいと思いますね
仕事をする時でも たくさん儲かるそうだからやるぞと言っちゃうと
欲であって執着であって
執着から生まれる集中であって
疲れますよ あれでは ではなくて
これは私がやらなくてはいけない仕事で
収入はどうでもいいんだけど
やっぱり自分に与えられた大事な仕事だから
これは完璧にやってやるぞというふうに
この愛着がなく 執着がなく
そのものに集中する そうするとすごい体が癒されてしまいます
心も癒されてしまいますし
能力も上がるし で さらにさらに仕事能力も上がって
どんどん集中力を身につけることになります
はい  ありがとうございます
次は 30代の女性の方ですね
体の状態 病気 怪我などに引きずられるように心の状態が悪くなってしまいます
どうすればいつも心が穏やかな状態を保てるのでしょうか？という質問です
あの体と心っていうのはすごい草練みたいな感じで
もう我々は生きているんですよ
この心は最大と力が持っていて
でも この力を発揮するチャンスは全くないんですね
ずっと肉体に依存しているんですよ
だからこのすごい高度な瞑想をして
限りは 我々は輪廻転生するとき
必ず肉体というか物体
何かの体を作るんですね
心が体がないと機能できないという誤解に陥っているんです
皆さんもそうなんですよ
目がなければ困るやとかね
耳がなかったら困るやとかね
舌の感覚なくなったらどうしようかとかね
死ぬほど怖くなるんです
でもそんなのはもう目耳の肉体だからね
どうして壊れるんですけど
心には本当は関係ないんですけど
心すごい臆病で 体にむちゃくちゃ依存するんですね
それで依存するんですけど
こんなもうアホな心が体を管理するんだから
体もろくなことないんで
どんな人の体を調べても
いろんなもう欠点というかね
欠陥というのはね あるんですよ
なんかおかしいところは必ずその体にあります
それで心の問題なの 逆にちょっとだけでも体に何か変化が起きちゃうと
心がびっくりして興奮してもう怖くなって
驚くんですね 驚いちゃうと
そのショックがまた体に入っちゃうんですね
入って もう体さらに壊れるんですね
だからいつでも悪循環になるんです
普通は肉体がいろいろ壊れても怪我しても
だいたいすぐ治ります
肉体はいろんな業の法則だけではなくて
種の法則もありますから
種子の法則 いわゆる種の法則ですね
ですから植物ですよ だから壊れたらもうそこはなんとかなります
治療しなくても治るんです
治療しなくても治るためには
肉体のこの種子の法則に任せておかないと
でも私たちは任せませんよ
病気になったら あ 大変だ
どうしよう 先生 治してくださいという風に興奮しちゃって
驚いちゃって 心を弱くするんですね
そうすると 植物なら 1週間で直すことが
体が心が肉体をいじってるんだから
これには 2  3ヶ月とかかかったりするんです
その時でも やがて病気があると
なんとなく病気に慣れちゃいますね
病気に慣れたら あ 別に驚くことじゃないという気分になるんですね
まあ私はこんなことだからということで落ち着くんです
そこでやっともう回復方法に行くんですよ
そういう関係なんですね
だから あまりにも肉体心配する人が早く病気になります
で 肉体のことは何のことなく
もう自分では子供みたいに
子供っていうのはあんまり体のことを気にしないんですね
特に男の子はね もう遊ぶことはもっと大事なんです
怪我してもそれはまあ別に構わない
で 親がこれはダメですよとか
ちゃんと殺菌してなんとか
まあいいや いいやと言うんですね
いいですよ すぐ治りますからね
で 逆に女の子はまた違うんですね
ものすごい体のことを気にするんですね
だからこの 心で悩んだり心配したりすることが
病気が長持ちすることになります
だから いつだっても肉体は肉体の法則で
遺伝子の法則で 種子の法則で
もうもうなんとかなるだろうと
もう私は関係ないんだと
あんたが勝手に病気になったら知ったことないよっていう調子でいると
結構もう早く治るんですね
だからいつでも心を穏やかにしたければ
まあもうまあそれ別にもう最後に出しましたからね
もう悩まないで 妄想しないで
もう慈しみの気持ちでいれば
まあ常に心が明るいんですよ
慈しみを実践する場合は
大体まあ 7割ぐらい病気はもう消えてしまうと思います
慈しみを実践する人に病気がある場合は
それはまあ業のプログラムで来ているもので
それはもうどうしもならないね
それはまあそのまま受け取るしかないですね
ああ そうですか それ以外の病気はほとんどないんですよ
慈しみを実践すると怪我もしません
で まあなんとなくなんかそれがガードになって体を守ってくれます
ですから 心を病気にならないようにっていうのは
お釈迦様の言葉がありますから
まあ毎日慈しみを実践してください
そうすると心は明るくなると思います
えーと 次はですね  30代の男性の方ですね
記憶についての質問です
ちょっと音を上げてほしいです
...ですけど 記憶過去妄想に暮れることによって様々な行為に出てしまいます
論語各割愛を滅してしまえば
記憶の妄想の種は放っておけとなり
お話終了であるでしょう
とはいえ なぜ今の私ではない過去の私が触れたものが保存されてしまうのでしょうか
記憶のメカニズムの仕組みについてご教示よろしくお願いいたします
という質問です  記憶は二つの働きで起こるものだと思います
一つは感情で 一つは理論的な明確な理性ですね
そこで一般の方々は誰でも感情で記憶するんですね
で 先に感情があって 感情が何かデータを引き起こすのです
だから 大した記憶じゃない
例えば怒り 怒りっぽい性格の人の記憶は全部まあ嫌なデータだけ
いわゆる自分に不親切にされたことばっかり
ほとんどそうなっちゃう
親切にされたことっていうのはもう忘れている
で 怒りっぽいなく まあなんとなくもうありがとうって自分で生きる人々は
もうそういう方向のデータたくさんね
助けてもらったことばっかりもう記憶しているんですね
だから何記憶するのかっていうことは
自分の性格からもわかります
だから記憶をどんなふうにするのかっていうことが
この まあ感情はどんな程度で働くのかっていうことなんです
それでいつも混乱状態で
興奮状態で 緊張状態でいると
無知が無知の感情が働きますね
そういう人々にはほとんど忘れるんですよ
物事は 私たちはどちらかというと
怒りか欲の感情で物事を記憶するんです
で それは一般人の方 やり方で
で しかし この理性で記憶する方法もあります
で 皆様 脳のこともよく私よりご存知だと思いますけど
脳っていうのは明確な論理立てがあれば忘れないんですよ
だから感情よりはこの論理性と理性では
もう脳にとってはすごい記憶しやすいんですね
そこで仏教ではこの理性っていうものを育てますから
至って簡単に好きなデータをいくらでも引き出せます
だから 嫌なデータであろうか
好ましいデータであろうか
もう好きなことはその瞬間で引き出せます
で だから理性育てた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
で 記憶といってもまた 2つあります
自分がそうだと思うこと
いわゆる自分の妄想なんですね
それを思い出しても 現実ではないので
正しい記憶っていうのは
この事実を思い出せることなんですね
本当に起きたことをそのまま思い出すことなんですね
で それで どこまで記憶能力あるのかというと
人間にそんなに大した記憶能力はないんです
まあ時々脳が特別な脳になっちゃって
何でも覚えちゃうという
これは物質的なんです
そういう人々もいますよ
もう一回見たら忘れられ
このまま覚えちゃうという
このフォトグラフィックメモリーとかある人々もいますね
あれははっきり言えば病気の一種なんですね
で もう全て起きた出来事を頭に記録しているというのは
それは脳の構造によってこのデータ記録できるということで
そういう人々はすごい後で不幸になって
人生はどうすることもできなくなっちゃって
大変なことになります
だから記憶にはいくらかの管理は必要なんです
全て記憶する必要もないんです
それで我々にはどんな程度で物事を覚えているのかというと
この自分の命を支える程度のことしか覚えていないんです
で なんで皆様方英語を学んでいるのに忘れているんですかね
毎日の人生に全然関係ないんだからでしょ
しかし 英語でなければ生きていられない場合は
何のことなくできるようになるんでしょ
その時は小学生で中学校で学んだものはドカンと出てくるんです
そういうことで 英語を覚えたんだけど忘れちゃったと今言ってますけど
命に関わってくると もう思い出してくるんです
だから我々は自分の命をなんとか守る程度の記録能力しか持ってないんです
なんで年取ってくると忘れますかね
ほとんどのことはいらないからなんです
いらないんです だからある程度で
このまあ認知障害になったっても
それそんなにどうったこともないんですけどね
でも ある意味で生きることの危うい状態になるんだから
これ問題なんですね だから認知症は本当に問題なんです
なぜかというと 自分の家も忘れちゃうと困るでしょ？自分の子供の顔も忘れちゃうと
おばあちゃんがね これ困りますね
朝ごはん食べたのに忘れちゃったって言っちゃうと
これ体に悪いですね だからこのそこまで記憶なくなってしまうのはかなり危険で
しかし 私たちはいくらいっぱい勉強したっても
年とともにどんどんどんどん減っていくんですよ
だから記憶するメカニズムっていうのは
どの程度で自分の命に関わりがあるのかいと
私は昔々 いろいろ言語を学ぶときはむちゃくちゃでね
フランス語とかね あれ
あの格変化あったりして
ドイツ語なんかむちゃくちゃですからね
で もうこれはもうむちゃくちゃ覚えられないやと思ったんですね
そこですぐそこはこの逆にしたんです
どうすれば この若いんだから
みんなとふざけて楽しく生きていたいでしょ
だからこのドイツ語でしゃべることはこれで楽しいやと
という感じで フランス語で喋るとこれが結構楽しいやとかね
で そちらの辺に行ったところで
全部自動的に格変化とかなんとかとか
全部もう出てくるんですよ
それでも相当当時で喋りましたからね
楽しかったんで だから自分が何語で喋るか喋るべきかって
よく忘れちゃって 人の顔を見たら
あ これはフランス語のクラスの友達やといって
もうフランス語しか出てこない
で ドイツ語のクラスの人々やその関係の人だったら
もう何のことなく ちょっとそのスイッチオンになって
そこを出ていけるようになったんです
当時て その楽しく生きていたんですよ
日本に来たらもう役に立たないし
生きることには何も役に立たない
そこで初めて大阪外大に入りましたけど
フランス語を学ぶ学生さんもいましたし
ドイツ語を専門にやる子供たち
若者たちもいます 子供たちはみんな大学生たちがすごく仲良く
わいわいと楽しく生活してたんだけど
そこで思ったんで じゃあこの子たちがね
大学で選考通ってドイツ語をやるならば
ドイツ語を喋るぐらい喋るだろうと
だって俺が 1ヶ月ぐらいで喋り出しちゃったんだから
なんであなた方はという感じで喋ったら一言もわからないんですね
で 発音は当然おかしいし
で いやいやと言うんですね
やられたと そこでフランス語をやっている子供たち
若者も同じで もうそれではなるほど
生きるためには必要で
あの子たちがフランス語を喋ったならば
若者とふざけてごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃで
みんなにわからないことをお互い喋ったりとかね
楽しかったのに もうやってくれないんですね
そこで同じ大学であってもね
もう二人がフランス語を喋るも
あまり誰もわからないとかね
これって結構面白いんですよ
だからそれで全部きれいさっぱり私の頭から落ちてしまったんです
なんか最近ちょっとまた勉強し始めたらどうかなと思ったんだけど
やっぱり自分の人生にも関係ないでしょ
だから脳に残らないんですね
そういうことで あの我々の記録能力っていうのは
この命を支えるために制限されています
だから皆様方 間違ってても生まれ死んでからね
犬になったらもういらんだからね ２
２足す２は４であることね
俺 全部きれいさっぱりその記録は忘れちゃいます
人間でいて 人間で死んで
そのまま人間の世界に戻ったら思い出しやすいんです
勉強は早いんです これ必要なものだから
そうなると過去の勉強もざっと出てくるんです
そんな程度なんですね
記憶は はい  ありがとうございます
次は 20代の男性ですね
現在大学 4年生で 来年就職しなければなりません
しかし 特にしたいこともなく
自分はどうしたいのかがいくら考えてもわかりません
それに このまましたくもない仕事をするような会社に入りたくはありません
これから先の道が全く見えません
どうしたら自分はどうしたいのかがわかるでしょうか
自由に心を落ち着いて生きていきたいです
アドバイスをお願いいたします
あの仕事なんかね そんなに大胆に取る必要はないと思います
自分のことは考えすぎなんですよ
夢見るのはもう自由ですけど
これ危険なんですね 現実的に見ると
我々はこの日で この日でなんとか生きてきただけなんですよ
この 4年生といっても
まず大学に入ったら 1年生だから
そこでやるべきことをやっただけで
2年生になったらその時やるべきことをやっただけで 4
年になったら就職活動とかいろいろやらなくちゃいけない
だから その日で その日でやるべきことをやればいいんです
だからいくつかの仕事を見つけて
まあ目を閉じて じゃあこちらにしましょうとね
決めたっても構わないと思いますよ
それは気楽で で 仕事にそんなに大胆な意味付けを付けてつけてはいけないんです
選ぶ場合は もうできるだけ単純な仕事を選ぶのはやりやすいということもありますね
しかし 私が言いたいところは
この仕事っていうのはとても逆に言えば大事なことなんです
仕事で人間が生きているんです
そこで仕事をする人は給料をもらうかもしれませんだけど
それと違って 仕事そのものが人々を助けることなんですね
だから皆様方は真面目に仕事をしないと
世の中は成り立たないんですよ
あの電車の運転手というのはごっつい面白くない仕事をやってますよ
びっくりするんで あんなつまらないことをよく何時間もやるんだから
しかし そういう人々はものすごい真剣にその仕事をするんだから
我々は死なずに済んでいるでしょうに
だから この世の中をね
もうちゃんと動かすために
仕事っていう項目がもう欠かせないものなんですね
だからどんな仕事でもそれは構わない
やる時はそれを真面目にやって
よくできましたと それぐらいのことで十分だと思います
そうではなくて 私たちは大事にするべきことは
仕事というより 我々は生まれてから死ぬまで生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
だから日々良い 人間になることは我々の一生の仕事なんですね
どんな会社に入るかっていうことじゃないんだよ
会社に入ったっても まあそんなずっとできるわけじゃないしね
だからこの日々良い より良い人間になることだけは一生の仕事にして
まあ収入を金もらうためにはなんとかするということでいいんじゃないかなと思います
だから あまりも将来の夢を考えたっても
現実的にはその日でその日で生きているだけの人生ですよ
誰でも 私も同じこと全然ここを今やってますけどね
こんなことは若い頃思い立ったこともないんです
私は年取るまで大学でいると思っていたんです
で もう結局辞めてしまいましたからね
そんなもんなんですよ
若い時はもうこれ想像もできないことでしたけどね
でもやらなきゃ辞めますと
で 辞めて まあそれでその日でその日でまあ生きてますよ
だからまあ昨日も何か用事がありましたけど
それで途中で今日講演がありますよと言われたらびっくりしちゃって
あ そうか もう再度作らなくちゃいけないし
データ作らなくちゃいけないと思って
もう家に入って まあ夜はそれはその仕事をやと
ワーッとデータを探して
もうつなげてつなげていて
それはそれで終わって
今日は喋って それはそれで終わって
まあその日でその日でまあ生きてるだけですよ
若い者も同じことをやってますよ
ただ認めたくない みんなに将来っていうこと長くあるんだからね
でもそんなの分かったことないでしょ
だからこの時間もったいないんで
私はどうすればいいかっていうこと
だからまあさっさとまあこちらにするぞということで
気楽に選んだ方がいいと思いますね
だから仕事ではないんですね
人生は別ですから 良い人間になることはね
どんな仕事を選んだってもできると思います
いろいろ勉強したり 自分の別世界を作ってほしい
自分の人格を向上する別なプログラム
それがずっとあるプログラムで
まあその時も収入も必要ですから
それはいろいろ仕事を選んでやればよろしいんですね
会社を退職したら それでも元気で生きているんだから
また別の仕事を見つけるとかね
そういうふうにしたら気楽にした方がいいと思います
ありがとうございます
次は 30代の男性です
仕事に関する質問だと思います
大きなプロジェクト全体を見渡すときに怖くてどうしようもなく
どうしようもなくなってしまいます
そんな時 救われる方法はありますか？ あの
あります その瞬間のセクションだけ見るんです
あの大きなプロジェクトがあっても
それはこの英語でセルと言うんですね
CELL いわゆるセクションですね
小さなセクションごとに物事を組み立てていくものなんですよ
だから この山ほどレゴの大量に見て
これはと思った たまげたなではなくて
何を作るのかっていうレイアウトを見て
1個1個重ねてはめておけばいいでしょ
だからこの大きなスケールで見ない方がいいんですよ
しかし その方にその答えで
これは能力の問題ですよ
で 私は個人的に何かを実行しようと思うと
まず全体的なイメージを作るんです
イメージを作って それからピシピシと小さなセクションにカットしていくんです
これ 瞬間でやります カットして大体もう 2 3 分あれば十分です
で 瞬間でカットして それで仕事を別にまたカテゴライズして
はい終わりと はい 実行やということになってくるので
実行になってきたら あんたこれやって
あんたこれやって あんたこれやってっていうだけで
そういう人々には全体的なピクチャーは見せません
みんなどうですかね あんたしっかりやりなさい
それだけ それで全部起動すると
参加した人はみんなびっくりするんですね
もう思ってもみなかった
こんなうまくいくとは思わなかったとかね
そこでみんなその喜びを味わっちゃうんです
もう想像もできなかった喜びをね
それはちょっとあのプロジェクトをランニングする人々の能力のことですから
能力ない方々はそんな困らなくてもいいんです
自分に与えられたパートだけやればいいんです
舞台と同じですよ 舞台で派手に見えますけど
誰も全部やってないんです
みんな小さなパートやってるだけでしょう
だからステージマネージャーにしたっても
いくつかのマネージャーがいるんですよ
照明やらね 踊りを見る人やらね
いろいろいますから それぞれ自分のパートやるんですね
例えば舞台で音声係は音だけ気をつけて
そこだけプロデュースすればよろしいんですね
照明係は照明をプロデュースすればいいんですね
だから あの  そんなもんなんですね
だからパートだけ見てください
大きなプロジェクトは
まああんなのは妄想だと
うまくいくかいかないか分かったもんじゃないでしょうにと
とにかく今はこれやらなくちゃいけないと
それだけに集中するんです
ありがとうございます
次  50代の女性の方ですね
感性を磨くことは大事だと言われますし
ものを見たり判断を迫られたりする時に
確かに感性の鋭さが大切なことだと思われます
仏教的に感性とは何でしょう？という質問
感性の本当の意味って何ですかね
漢字は何ですか？ 漢字に正確な性
私は日本語の辞書を持っていないな
これ 英語の単語調べますかね
ちゃんと意味がわからないと
ちょっと ん？センシティブじゃないと思いますね
うん うん まあセンシティブですね
感受性とか  英語の単語は出てこない
センシビリティー  センシビリティー
センシビリティ どちら
センシビリティー  うーん
そこで質問で何聞いてるんですか？感性は
仏教的には何でしょう？どういうものでしょう
うーん なんか経典でもそこを似ているところは
ある ありますけどね  これなんかね
無理に強引に育てることはできないようだと思います
で もう一人一人がちょこちょこちょこちょこでそこを訓練してみるしか
このこれっていう方法はないと思います
一応 仏教的に言えば この
最終的にみんなに役に立つ結果を出す
だから料理作ったんだからって
それだけではなくて みんなああ良かったな
美味しい料理だなというね
楽しいな 美味しいなという風に
この満遍なくいろんな方面でもう喜びを感じる料理で
その場合は完成ということになるんですね
ただ まあご飯代でもなんとかなんとかはいはいで襲って出すのもできますけどね
だからこのそうやってこの最終的な結果でいい結果を出すと
結果まあこれもちょっともうあった方がいい
これもうちょっとあった方がいいという風に
我々よく気付いちゃいますからね
それは感性しています
ことに完成がちょっと足らないということになってきますね
だからこの今 仏教的にはこのこの悟っている
悟る方々っていうのはね
お釈迦様でもたくさんいらっしゃいましたけども
時々この完成能力が現れる学者もいるし
現れない学者もいるんですよ
悟って煩悩は何もない
解脱していますけど あの
何が悟ったのかとかね
人にどう喋ればいいのかどうかね
これよくわからないんですね
だから黙っているんです
で 頼まれて何か教えてくれと言ったら
自分が自分が覚えている何か言葉一つ二つ教えるだけで
もう時々教典があるんですね
時々若いお坊さんたちにすると
もう本人が悟りに達していますけど
私にはまあこれ以上質問しないでくださいと
で 私はこういう風に こういう風に
これこれやって知ってますけど
それ以上以上はもう聞かないでくれと
で そこで完成がないっていうことをはっきり言うんですね
そこで仏教の場合 サーリプッタ尊者とかは
あのむちゃくちゃ能力があって
みんな同じ悟りなんですけど
サーリプッタ尊者がもうお釈迦様は説法を途中でやめたら
何のことなくそこからずっと結論まで持っていくんです
相当な能力でしょ お釈迦様は比丘たちをなんとかなんとかと話し始めると
サーリ尊者がお釈迦様はまずこれを説明して
次にこれを説明して 次にこれを説明して
最後にこういう風に終了するだろうともうわかっているんです
なぜお釈迦様はそれを知っているんだから
時々されるって もう疲れましたから
続けてくださいと出ていくんです
そういうことである人もない人もいますからね
まあそんなにまあ気にしなくていいんじゃない？こんなことは
で あまりにもダサくてね
だらしなくて生きるのはよくないんですね
まあまあできるだけ まあもうちょっとベターなものをやろうというふうな
毎日頑張った方がいいんです
でも完璧にうまくいかなくてもね
例えばこのマイケルジャクソンのビデオを見たんですけど
この 完成度っていうのはもうもうびっくりのびっくりでしょうし
私はそこで秒に切ってみるんですよ
1 秒半分半分ぐらいに切ってね
何も見えませんね これはどうかいというところは
だから彼が何か何て言いますか
あれ 踊りですか？踊りを作る場合は
これはもう 1 秒のね もう 4 分の 1 単位で考えてるでしょ
そこで一つのポーズは何秒見せるのかという
そこは全部精密に考えて計算して作るんですね
だけど しかし 日本でも若者いっぱい頑張ってるでしょ
プロたちがいっぱい集まって
これはうまくいかないんですよ
いろいろ見えますね もういろいろ
ここはどうかな ここはどうかなとかね
だからまあいいんじゃない？それで
だから完成度がものすごくシャープな人が
まあそれやればいいし
でもそれぐらいのツケもありますよ
あまりにも完成度が高い人っていうのはむちゃくちゃ苦労するんですよ
もう自分をもう燃やしてしまいますからね
だからまあ もういいと思う
まあ悪いものじゃないんだけど
まあまあほどほどでいいんじゃないかなと思いますね
あっていいんだけど あまりにも完璧な完成度があっちゃうと
もう生きていられないと思います
そういうところで まあそういうふうに
まあ中途半端でいいんじゃないかなと思います
それでは質問とも1時間以上過ぎましたので
次の質問で最後にさせていただきたいと思います
30代の男性の方の質問です
この方 写真を撮ることが好きで
趣味と言ってもいいと思います
最近 それが執着なのではないかと考えるようになりました
写真を撮ることは行為として執着なのか
また 撮ることや写真を見た人が感じた結果によって
善行とも悪行ともなり得るのか
今考えているところです
ご助言いただけましたらございましたらお願いします
やり方次第で善行でも悪行にもなります
ですから 私たちは趣味で構わないんだけど
それで何を表現したいと思っているのかとかね
ただ時間潰しかなとかね
まあ個人的になんとなくつまらない人生を面白くするためということかとかね
まあそれはまあ そんなに善と悪とも言えることではないんですから
つまらなくいるよりは退屈でいるよりは
心を明るく活発にした方がいいということで
まあ個人的な趣味で写真にかかるのも構わないし
写真で何か表現したいと思っているならば
その表現したいと思うことによって善にもなるし
悪にもなるしね だからそこを考えてください
例えば動物の写真を撮るとね
動物はとても美しく可愛く生きているんだということを表現したいのか
動物たちも人生って大変だろうということを表現したいのかどうかね
あるいはあの なんかテレビで出る予定ですけど
韓国のね 昆虫のビデオをいっぱい撮って
昆虫のサバイバルというかね
どうやって交尾して相手を誘惑するのかっていうところだけ出すみたいですけど
だから それ見てああ 大変だなとかね
やっぱり生きることっていうのは誰にでも同じことというメッセージが伝えてくると
いいメッセージを伝えているんですね
そうすると そのセクションがいいとは言えますね
だから そこは個人で決めなくちゃいけない
ただ 欲を表現したくて出しちゃうと
これは悪いことになっちゃうし
うーん まあそんなもんですね
だからこれはもう自分で決めるんですね
まず まあ趣味として明るく生きる手段としてのところは
別に善でも悪でもなく
まあどちらかというとまあいいんじゃないかなというふうな方に入ります
つまらなく生きているよりは
脳をちゃんと活発にした方が良いことですね
人にも見せてもらいたいということになってくると
何を表現しているのかということね
あんたすごいねとか言われてほしければ
あんまり良くないんです
褒めてもらいたいとかね
あんたの腕はすごいやとかね
それはただエゴですね
この写真見て感動しましたとかいう風になってくると
いいことかもしれない
そこら辺は個人的に決めた方がいいと思います
はい  ありがとうございました
それではまだまだたくさんいただいておりますが
時間の関係でこれにて終了させていただきたいと思います